they taste a bit tougher tougher tougher
what the no no no no what the you can
cook a tuna to taste as good as a steak
you can do it you can do I
disagree hello and welcome to another
episode of trash taste I'm your host for
today G and I'm joined again once again
by the boys baby a a human audio glitch
did you did you just buff no no it it
was like the the PS2 disc when it
scratches
and one another trash taste just we
haven't started drinking yet that is
just the perfect way to describe my
brain I'm just like sometimes you just
glitch out and you're like okay um let
me try that again so I don't know what
do we call in this episode by the way we
drank every beer in Japan but it's not
because we have a [__] budweis well
we just you just went to the store and
picked up a bunch yeah so I have a I
have a store near my house uh that sells
like a bunch of like like and by a bunch
I mean like like 200 different types of
canned coft beers wow um chose a no okay
I didn't pick that I didn't pick that
that was that was that was I don't want
to I don't want to start like nameing
names but how is this
14,400 Yen that's like $11 well I mean
that's how much you'd pay for a CW beer
well it is called oil of angels so
perhaps it must be good this one's
called Vegas as [__] I picked out the
ones with funny names which uh you
definitely has to be Vegas 7.7% on a
bloody beer yeah IPA I swear to God
they're just trying to get people fu up
they don't even like Flavor they're like
you don't want to drink wine okay well
we're going to trick you to drinking
wine you you want do you want to pick
one
first I mean I haven't tried any of
these before but I guess what's this one
this is tessellation Lone Pine from
Portland Main oh wow yeah yes yeah every
beer in Japan [__] we just got a
bunch of American crap here I might pick
the I might pick Vegas as
[__] for this one um I'll take this one
then ation you going to have the oil of
angels it's 7.7% I'm going be [__]
after I mean these are all like pretty
bad this is 6.5 so it's not that much so
much alcohol you spilled it
every all right sure I'll have the oil
of angels it's the it's a hazy Indian
paleale oil of angels is a hazy IPA
brewed with spout Ryan oats hopped with
an wait what what this can't be
hopped with an ethereal combination of
Galaxy Mosaic eal
Simco I've never thought I would
describe a beer using the word thatal
Jesus mine's very hazy yeah so do you
know the difference between an Indian
Pale and a pale is uh one's Indian uh
well
no uh I think guess the difference is
that it's just generally just less
alcohol than a pale that's pretty much
the same same same Brewing method as I
like I know you really like hazy uh no P
are my favorite oh like P I like ipas oh
you like yeah I remembered one of you
really liked IP yeah let's pour it let's
[__] it up you know I I actually saw I
actually saw a video I know I saw it too
is is it the video with like the beer
expert that's like you should you should
let the beer foam up actually everyone's
like gaslighting people into not letting
the beer foam up to be fair if you don't
want to be bloated it is a better way of
drinking beer but if you like being
bloated and you want the beer to taste
better who wants to be bloated well okay
okay listen I do think that the beer
tastes better when you don't do this cuz
it's more carbonated and I feel like it
has a better flavor but if you don't
want to be bloated then this is the
better way all
right I mean I'm still not going to do
it listen listen I'm just I'm trying it
I'm testing it out [__] H what's the
color right Che Cheers Cheers boys so
we're recording this episode this
Tuesday and it'll be out Saturday yeah
so we thought we'd do uh a timely
episode okay well timely in some sense
time timely in some sense and since
Conor has another yet another flight to
catch F to [__] off to America again
giving you the [__] Vegas as [__] I'm
going to Vegas you're going to Vegas you
know we haven't had a chance to catch up
it's been basically been since M's
episode right that well cuz yeah I went
on the RV tra which felt like a year and
that was like a day because uh that was
the day of recording so I haven't had a
chance to catch up with the boys since
we've been traveling really uh so we
thought hey why not uh try a bunch of Ja
beers and uh just catch up how's the RV
trip by the way I haven't asked yeah
were you supposed to come G I don't know
bailed he bailed on me really I did I
did see like just I just straight up
said I can't yeah he said he could so
you know to be fair to be fair I was
like I did genuinely want to come uh
because I came on the last one it was
like a lot of fun uh I just had way I
just you know I think the tour put me
back way more than I thought it was
going absolutely it did uh because I
thought in my in my naive little mind
then I'm like I'm going to be in England
for an extra week and a half after tour
no one's going to want to meet up or
hang out I can just work in my England
house and I'll catch up to work all then
JK when you were in a [__] different
country and your family's like uh excuse
me why are you not why are we not
meeting why why why why are you not
being a good family member ande I feel
that's especially the true for you cuz
it's like I I bet when you're back home
like you're just like you're 30,000
cousins are just like all right I mean
you got to make time for all of us you
yeah yeah and also catching up with
mates as well so just I I I had planned
to do a few more working days but
unfortunately well you know you got to
make time for the friends and family and
unfortunately something had to go and it
was the RV trip I'm sorry Conor I'm
sorry do to me it's fine this tastes bad
by the way this tastes bad that didn't
taste good does yours taste good it's
hazy right so this probably tastes
pretty good I imagine just
sweet this tastes very
hoppy oh it's very hoppy w I like that
though I don't think it's well actually
no it's kind of sweet I don't try this I
I just don't rate it do do you like this
one I think sometimes the hazy ones go
the the in America some hazy ones go way
too hazy oh that's a bit too sour for me
yeah it's kind wait let me try yours
yours this is the kind of
car yeah it's not bad yeah American ipas
man sometimes I like them but sometimes
they're just too much it's a hit on yes
uh but yeah no I um it went really well
I think I improved a lot on the first
one mhm I tried to we had like last time
we had like just one car following us
this time we had two cars so Nabi was
always going ahead and sorting
everything out so when we got there we
could just jump right into it um fil
franker style and uh yeah but did you
have fun yeah it was really fun it was
super it was super it was super I don't
give a I don't give a [__] about the
technical details tell me about the fun
I missed out on me it's like it's a mix
right Logistics if the logistics go well
I can have more fun because then
everything's going perfectly from my
perspective but but like yeah it was it
was very fun I was yeah uh it it was uh
we were in the RV a lot less than last
time but it was really fun I think uh we
had some really fun activities that I
didn't think we're going to be as fun as
they they
were um like we did pottery making that
was really fun MH um dud we did so much
how was the Tuk Tok driving dude that
was so fun I can't believe you would
appropriate my culture like this own
entertainment there's just a dude in ISU
who's just like yeah so we we shipped it
off to Japan uh to Thailand they shipped
it back in and oh my God that [__] was
impossible to drive initially yeah um
and it sounded like it was being choked
out cuz it was manual as well oh [__]
okay did you know that all tooks a
manual uh yeah oh I've never driven one
but I you know I've seen people drive it
it's like a rickety [__] car that's a
manual it's like a hybrid bike and a
it's really not fun to drive it's not
fun to be in is as well no and I was I
was ABS because it's been so long since
I've driv a manual uh and and it didn't
help that the car was kind of hard to
drive like the the accelerator when you
pull it down it would and you let go it
would just stay oh so when you wanted it
to get back down to to nothing it was
very hard to like physically keep doing
it but then also if you did it a little
bit over when it was on zero it would
start revving so I was really confused
the whole time and I I I was either over
revving or under revving constantly and
I was always in the wrong gear and the
[__] me the gear box was so [__] on it
and I couldn't do it but then I went
first sounded like it was dying L did it
it sounded perfect and I was like [__]
basically you experienced what it was
like for me when I first drove a manual
guess just absolute chos when we drove
the manual uh in that place when we
drove the manual cars that time I found
it really not not bad at all to drive
that but my God this TK Tok was so hard
and I was just not I guess it been so
long but it was really fun uh the Tuk to
driving actually was was a really big
cuz I didn't know what we were going to
do I just planned a and then we'll
figure it out we ended up doing like a
Kind of Crazy Taxi like go and pick up
something from the Comin and bring it
back
um my God being in that car on the road
is terrifying cuz just when you would
take turns it felt like it was going to
flip yeah it it's not fun um and you
could hear it from like two miles away
it always feels like you need to treat
treat it like a motorcycle you know uh I
don't know how the center of gravity is
on that [__] yeah it's a motorcycle
with like a bit of extra width and you
can have passengers for some reason
thick motorcycle apparently it's
completely road legal as well in Japan
like the guy I mean obviously it is cuz
he's offering that service but I was
like I can't believe Japan allows
otherwise you would have just committed
a I just can't believe it's allowed on
the road I just I was like what really I
guess it's got mirrors and indicators so
that and seat belts so that's normally
like actually the front didn't have seat
belts cuz maybe because it's a bike huh
I don't
know we just like dissect what it is
right now have seat belt I don't think
it did have seat Bel no maybe I don't
know I don't think it would as as a tie
resident I don't think it would have a
seat belt I would be amazed if it had a
seat
belt on a Tuk Tuk yeah that was uh it
was interesting went to a zoo that was
fun but you would have came and you
would have done uh canyoning which is
really fun what's canyoning uh it's
where you jump off and slide off
waterfalls oh that sounds fun and an
easy way to get an injury but that
sounds yeah we had these um well it was
sucked cuz the stream that one day the
signal was really bad yeah I assume you
were in like the forest or something
right yeah and we normally would have
used starink to kind of as a backup but
because it was like raining and it was
really hard to get a satellite for some
reason I can't and there was trees and
[__] so it was it was not good but um
people got to see the end which is fun
but uh I was talking to the there our gu
were just like these two Tibetan dudes
or how it's always just two Tibetan
dudes always end up being the guides for
dangerous things um I go you look like
Mr Beast and I was like I don't I don't
think I look like Mr Beast but I I I
have this conversation with him and I go
um I was he go tell me she's from Tibet
and I was like oh cool cool uh and he
was like do you know uh Mount Everest I
was like yeah I know Mount Everest he's
like some people don't know Mount
Everest and I was like who the [__] [__]
doesn't know I was like who didn't know
what Mount Everest was can you can you
tell me who this poser didn't know what
Mount Everest was I don't believe it
he's like you should do it it's fun I
was like you mean climb ever like yeah
yeah I was like don't people die on the
trail I was like isn't it like super
overcrowded and you can't do without a
show he's like maybe I was like you just
do it like a Mr Beast challenge you know
big hill what's the worst that get up
and just keep going up I mean there's
there are B death D care yeah but
they're also the majority of them are
living like 4,000 m above sea level and
they just think that's normal so it's
like you know to them it's just like oh
it's just like a slightly bigger Hill
they so built there like born in like
10g gravity or whatever like Goku trains
and you know they come back one third
the oxygen level like this is fine they
come back down and you're like people
breathe like this yeah they go to sea
level and they're just like it's too
much
oxygen um but it was really fun and then
right after that I went to go and watch
uh uh tatso y I'm so [__]
jealous so good godamn it was hard
getting a ticket yeah I bet um I had to
enter a lottery to get a ticket and then
I got a ticket but it was assigned to
and even doing that was a nightmare that
was I'm underselling how hard this was
it's very [__] difficult it's such a
pain in the ass and you need a Japanese
phone number yeah um so if you have a
foreign phone number you they which
wouldn't accept it um and it was tied to
your ID which there's a thing apparently
in Japan they do this where concert
tickets are tied to your ID and when you
go in I thought okay well that's okay
they won't check it it won't be
important but no they checked it at the
door that the your ID matched with your
ticket yeah it's supposed it's supposed
to stop
scalpers um So I entered this Lottery
paid $140 to enter this Lottery to get a
ticket and I got a ticket and then I
went to pog Champs in America in August
at some time yep and L was coming and it
happened to be where the day after uh
the RV stream ended yeah it was that was
the concert and I remember I I brought
it up to lwi and then I found afterwards
it was like his favorite song was by
yamasa and so I was like oh okay well
I'll try and get you a ticket no
promises um and I I just couldn't get
him a ticket like I entered the the the
the lottery again couldn't get one
entered the cancellation thing again
couldn't get one and then he was like
you bastard you betrayed me how dare you
go without me I was like dude what do
you I can't do anything I I could buy
listen if if this isn't America money
can't fix every problem here you you
just lose a lottery and that's life here
everything Goa yeah how's the concert
though dude it was insane yeah I [__]
bet I was so jealous the best concert I
think I've ever been to oh [__] I
thought cuz the man was like 70 that it
would he would sound older cuz he did
all these songs like 40 years ago yeah I
thought oh maybe he's getting old now
and he can't do it bro no bro I hadn't
lost a single bit it was crazy it was 3
hours is that is that am I crazy that's
long that's of just him singing that's
long no no
no normally a Sit is like an hour and a
half two hour it was just 3 hours uh and
I asked people I was like is there like
a supporting thing before like what time
should I go and they're like no no no in
Japan there's no supporting I just like
to think it was actually Yar story just
being like listen I have too many
bangers um I can't cut any I think so I
I it just has so many good songs that it
was impossible like cuz even some of the
songs that I really liked like uh
someday didn't get played and I was like
what the [__] somay is like a banger
yeah it is um yeah I've I've grown a new
appreciation for you know singers
especially in concerts that do a really
really long set after doing our own yeah
after like doing our own live show which
is 2 hours and sometimes just [__]
somehow arguing about bread on stage for
a good one segment of our show my voice
is like I could feel the tiredness Of My
Voice by the end of this show and I'm
like what [__] singers do it by
themselves for Two Plus hours crazy God
godamn it's almost like they go through
vocal
training okay okay there Joe insane I
know I'm sure you some of you might know
his music right on time uh what else uh
I'm blanking now Morning Morning Glory
what's that what's that yeah song what's
what's that one um it's shine shine is
my favorite shine great one he did the
Christmas one that's really popular as
well everyone knows the song in Japan it
was just reallyy good but it was like it
was kind of nuts i' never been in a I
thought Man 3 hours a long time I will
admit an hour and a half in I was like
kind of dozing out at one point cuz I
was like but it was like it was like a
really long song uh like a ballad I
don't really care about his ballad songs
that much cuz remember I'm a fake fan um
it was like n it was like a 9 minute
song and there's what dude it was it was
so weird cuz like I've never been to a
concert where he was just like I don't
know if he was ad living or what like
halfway through his songs he would just
start ad living yeah in a really cool
way it was really really fun um
uh and there was so many points where he
would just be like all right sack solo
time for like a minute and the dude go
for a sack solo and it was just so [__]
[__] hype yeah would just tear it up
for a minute that's that's a real artist
when you can like switch it up from like
the studio version and it slaps just as
hard if not sometimes harder yeah cuz
like every I think half the songs at
some point he would just go on like a
riff or do something else that was
really cool I was like oh my God this is
extended solos and [__] yeah they had
like a whole like a set that was moving
as well and like light up it was really
cool godamn um and yeah that dude it was
just so cool I just like especially
right on time right on time was so good
M cuz it was like oh he went off stage
he didn't sing it then he came back and
everyone was like oh my God obviously
was going to happen how big was this
concert like was it pretty big or wasow
4,000 capacity oh yeah that's big um it
was really strange cuz it was like no
one it was like I think also I saw an
article that was like he had shouted at
someone mid song and stopped singing
because they was they were like singing
along in the audience she like shut the
[__] up this is my song this is my
moment so it's it's like picture it it's
like the most biggest bangers of your
life yeah dead silent no one is allowed
weird no one's allowed to move no one is
allowed to dance no one is allowed to
take pictures which I agree with but
like no one is allowed to do anything
until you are signal to clap and then
you can start everyone can clap together
like this and then finally like two hour
two and a half hours in they finally let
you all stand up and then everyone kind
of starts doing like that kind of like
half dance for they go oh like the aunt
at a wedding dance yeah because dude I
rock up to this concert everyone's 60 oh
yeah oh okay everyone is old uh no other
foreigners as well I couldn't find a
single other Foreigner it was just me
surrounded by a bunch of old people
which I was happy with yeah uh it was
just it was very interesting CU I felt
like it was when you watch those like
North Korean crowds kind of felt like
that where it was like we were not
allowed to express anything until you
are told to start clapping and singing
like that's that's a big ask for that
kind of music as well right cuz it was
like like when we went to the cigaros
concert right it makes sense that we
were like sitting and still because that
was the vibe of the music and it's like
even if you wanted to sing along ain't
no one in that crowd knows Icelandic
right so it's like you can't sing along
even if you know how it goes so like
that makes sense but like y much music
is made for singing and dancing too so
the fact that they were like uh yeah so
enjoy the concert by the way you're not
allowed to express any fun whatsoever
until we tell you to it's a bit weird
yeah it was that was the only thing that
I kind of I I guess I mean I guess for
other some other people they maybe in
Japan as well they appreciate that they
can just have that like experience not
having to worry about any other like
sensor sensory like distractions I mean
sure but there was one Japanese dude one
Brave man down in the front who was just
going like full like the Calton dance in
the front like it was going crazy like
and no one else was dancing and I was
like the balls on this man to do it I I
respect it I respect it hell yeah dude
it was such an amaz I've already decided
because apparently he does it every
single year he does like a four four
month long uh tour every single year in
Japan so I'm definitely going back if he
does it again I mean we should all try
and go next year oh fun fact you can't
buy tickets in more than groups of two
oh awesome so if you you can only apply
in groups of two oh sorry gone you're
going to have to stay behind and so
let's so we could all apply as groups of
two right but if one of the you wins
Lottery the other group can't like me
and J Mighty get tickets might not or we
all might get tickets and we can also
next to each other me and Joey will be
next to each other but you won't be next
yeah this is like insane like I just
don't understand how there's not a
better way that's that's weird because
every concert I've been to in Japan
where it's like a lottery system it's
always the max is always four really
this one was two that's weird I've never
heard of two CU I fig I'm saying when I
when I applied for Taylor Swift tickets
which I'm I'm seeing Taylor Swift in
February by the way in uh in Japan wow
by the way which is like out of left
field but uh did it cuz uh Sydney's mom
is like a massive you to the lottery huh
you went to the lottery yeah we had to
enter the lottery and somehow we won on
like Taylor Swift tickets as well you
can also like Mass purchase lotteries
but problem is if you win all like four
or five you you you already paid the
deposits they just take your money yeah
so it's a it's a huge G so that's when
you have to like start ringing up people
being like hey I got tickets you want's
the thing though if you that that's why
I didn't get any extra tickets cuz you
had to sign everyone up with the full
IDs and mobile numbers and if you won on
that lottery ticket with that ID you
were not allowed to change it that is
weird which I never heard of that I hate
that they did this because I I feel like
yes scalping is a huge issue and there
needs to be S done about it and this is
definitely one way of combating it but
there should also be an probably a we
can make it equally as convoluted and
complicated we can make it impossible
but there should be a way that you can
transfer the ticket if you have a
genuine reason to someone else make it
really really difficult so scalping
becomes a pain in the assh yeah um cuz
scalping is [__] [__] move and
that that needs to like I don't know how
you combat it without going through this
much but yeah but the fact that I can't
if I have like three mates I can't go to
a concert and sit next to all of us it's
like [__] like that's I mean you you
sacrifice the experience and it's
because of the [__] scalpers at the
end of the day
unfortunately um but I mean I I feel
like two is a little bit of a low number
should be at least four we've seen
America's America's method of combatting
now they've made it so that if you make
over I think it sound like it wasn't a
lot it was like maybe a or less than
$1,000 if you make over $1,000 selling
tickets you get taxed quite a lot so now
they're being punished by the IRS the
ultimate the ultimate punishment the
ultimate Moon killer yeah they realized
The Ticket Master was the enemy of my
enemy is my friend actually there this
one en you can count on the like to to
smack down on a group of people being
[__] it's the tax man yeah they just say
they come down uh Sometimes good
sometimes bad normally bad but
occasionally they ever win was that the
first concert you had ever been to in
Japan yeah I'd been to really small
concerts but they were all like friends
or it was never like a really big one
never a a Japanese artist but I want to
go to more City pop ones it' be fun yeah
hell yeah like I want to go see hry live
that'd be fun or Mari uh teesa yeah
she's teesa now she's married toes uh
that'd be fun to watch she's got bangers
too yeah absolutely but I mean T's got
so many bangers back to back got so he's
got to stop you you you know some a b
when when Conor is getting this
passionate about beeps and boops well
you listen to the cuz he we relased the
ride on time album and it's literally
just like all his bangers and it's just
like 50 minutes of just non-stop bangers
absolutely so good that that I've been
trying to get that vinyl for ages now
and like the cheapest I found it for was
like
$500 wait oh the original oh they have
the re-release one which came yeah but I
want the original that'd be impossible
and I just can't find it and when I have
found it it's like would you like to pay
$2,000 for an LP I'm like no oh also mid
song I guess this is a thing in Japan uh
he would he would just talk a bunch oh
yeah that is a thing in Japan they do a
bunch of talking and uh a bunch of
people would laugh occasionally but the
one that got like the biggest shock
reaction I guess this is Jaan thing at
one point he goes uh yes I haven't drank
in two years and everyone
goes it's
like they never reacted the whole crowd
gasped and I've never seen anything like
this in I swear some like some like
in Japan with like a primarily Japanese
audience like when the artist starts
mcing and like there's an audience
reaction it just sounds like a sitcom it
was like mostly like laughs and it was
and and uh CU he was talking about like
just how he's old that was his main joke
that he kept saying um and he was like I
don't know why people I don't know why
there's young people here I didn't
listen to old people when I was young he
just called
you he saw you and he was just like
didn't know foreigners were here as well
yeah yeah so and he's making fun of some
of the laws that Japan was trying to
make it was very I'm sure I'm sure if
they could if translate everyone got Bas
yeah very
based um but that was very interesting I
guess because it's the older demographic
old people in Japan all old people in
Japan drink yeah I don't think I've met
a single person in Japan over the age of
50 that doesn't drink my granddad really
damn he he never drank damn it's so rare
in Japan but he smoked like
seven got
a choose one I reckon he a he's Proby a
stoner that was born in the wrong
country I don't know about
that he loved his mbor that's for
sure yeah yeah I mean I I've only been
to a few concerts in Japan but they all
pretty much follow that formula
especially if it's a Japanese artist
it's very different from like the kind
kind of like they they always have a
story behind like every after every song
or preceding like every song about a
little monologue about something going
on their lives when I wrote this song I
was 30 years old and I was at a turning
point in my life this is It's always
some [__] like that and I'm just like
that's cool and all but like just you
know it's it's it's fine like I I I get
the law and it's like it's sentimental
and it's cool and stuff like that but
it's like after a while you go to enough
concerts and it's like oh let me guess
yeah you wrote this song when it was a
turning point in your life all right
cool near the end of the show there was
like this merch presentation live where
like some guy kept handing like like a
like was on an easel like merch kept
coming out on a stand it was very funny
it was very Japanese it was and here we
have exhibit a merch number one please
go buy it and then he was just very fun
I I love like the the the dichotomy
between like a Japanese artist in Japan
and how they do their concerts versus a
western band or artist cuz like you know
cuz when I went to go see the pillows it
was very similar whereas like you know
like cuz it was it was also like uh you
know during like the beginning of CO as
so it's like you're not allowed to like
cheer you're not allowed to like take
videos and photos which is one that's
very I'm sure you weren't allowed to
take videos and photos no I I I want I
wanted this just take one little picture
just for Memories the set was so cool
but there was a dude literally right
behind me he would have he would have CL
me yeah exactly and it's like and you
know there's always like some MC
segments and all that like it's it's
kind of formul leg like when I went to
go see like Bad Religion at the punk
spring uh there was a huge sign at the
beginning of the gig that was just like
uh no crowd surfing oh okay you know and
like no moshing there was like two big
signs that just like that bad religion
came out and they were like [__] these
signs start moshing start crowd surfing
right now [__] the police oh my God and
then immediately Japanese people like
well I mean if they say
so three dudes start Crow surfing I'm
just like there we go that's what's up
that's the way to go yeah that's how
that's how you go to punk con it's not
in the contract like they just didn't
give a [__] meanwhile I'm I'm really
hoping that when I go see the tlor Swift
concert that she does that thing about
when she introduces the song I haven't
seen it before until it started blowing
up on TI to but she has like this really
cheesy kind of like introduction to
every song you know those times when you
see a boy and you just think to yourself
wow he's going to be trouble and then
trouble stops playing wait is that is
that what she
does sounds great every at the beginning
of every single Taylor Swift concert
she's like my name is Taylor Swift and I
was born in
1989 and everyone's
like is this real it's real there's so
many Tik toks of it it's so funny I did
not know how big of a deal TL like I
knew she was a big deal but I did not
know how big of a deal it was to go to
like one of her live concerts until
until like we somehow managed to get
tickets you know for Sydney's mom's uh
birthday uh and only when I started
telling people they're like what you got
ticket you got to see Taylor Swift live
cuz I I saw there was an article that
like when she goes to a city to do a
concert it has like such a big economic
effect on that City it's almost like the
super Bowl going to that city which well
this this current like uh tour that
she's on right now it's like spanning
for like a year and a half and it's
considered to be one of the biggest and
most lucrative tours ever in the music
industry damn like I can't imagine I
just what what is she doing man dude
she's [__] Scrooge MCD ducking like
everything like she's drowning m is
weird cuz I knew she was really popular
but it kind of felt like just this year
in particular just became crazy yeah I
don't know why maybe the tour maybe it's
for the tour maybe it's the tour but
it's also cuz like Taylor Swift fans a
are like insane come on man don't
disrespect them call them swifties all
right swifties swifties godamn okay I
guess you can talk about this cuz
Sydney's mom is the head of the Swifty
Council she is literally like the head
of the Swifty Council in her like local
area like you know you know how uh
basically you know how like most most
places have like a neighborhood watch or
something you know they the Swifty watch
they have the Swifty watch and she and
she basically runs that she was such a
big like Swifty that that there was like
some ticket controversy or some ticket
issues in like the America Tour that was
going on the tiet master thing The
Ticket Master thing uh and you know news
uh news outlets were doing reports on it
and uh one of the people they contacted
was Sydney's
mom and uh like live just now we have
the representative of the Swifty
Community here in Wisconsin it's just
it's just Sydney's mom so you know
Sydney's had her 15 minutes of fame but
she's never been on national TV before
as cuz her mom's been now been on
national tv as Swifty so that is that is
now her title awesome but yeah it's it's
like she tells me stories about just
like all of like the Taylor Swift fans
like worldwide doing meetups and no
matter where she goes in the world she
always have she always has like people
that she can hit up because there are
swifties all over the world that she can
kind of do a Meetup with uh and I'm like
this is this is an insane Network right
now it's it's crazy it's like it's
almost it's dare I say almost
cultish it is a little bit it is kind of
scary you know when you like you know
cuz like personally like I think Taylor
Swift just okay like she's made some
hits a lot of her stuff I think is just
kind of mid but like godamn if I said
that to a I'd be scared to say that to a
Swifty even if I know they might be cool
with me they be like which era did you
listen to
it's like oh yeah I like a couple of
songs and then be like name all of them
you know like I like I know that if I
you know went up to Sydney's mom and I
was just like you know full respect to
Taylor Swift um I just think she's okay
you know if I said anything else I know
Sydney's mom would be cool with it yeah
Sydney's mom is a lovely lovely person
she wouldn't say anything it would just
like she'd just probably die inside a
little bit I'm just jealous I wish I was
that passionate about something I am too
you know uh I wish I was a fan of
something like that but I just I just
don't get like that we're coming to you
live straight from the trash St office
to tell you that this episode is
sponsored by vessie it is no
exaggeration when we say that vessis are
the only shoes that we all wear because
they're perfect for any situation rain
sleep snow or shine you can guarantee
that we'll be wearing and rocking out on
a brand new pair of vessie shoes and
don't forget that they're waterproof as
well when I was in England just over a
month ago I did not care if it was
raining I didn't care if I stepped in a
puddle because I was wearing some
vessies baby vess right now have come
out with some brand new stuff including
the Soho shoes that are 100% waterproof
with a gusseted tongue Dynamax
technology synthetic leather exterior
grippy out SS non-marking out sauce and
a wax finished lace scissor guys they're
not just doing shoes right now we got
jackets as well look at this damn are
you wearing the overcast vessie jacket
right now Joey they've already taken
over my entire Shoe Closet I'm ready for
them to take over my entire wardrobe as
well with a soft fleece lining a relaxed
fit a Ragin sleeve design adjustable
Hood soft curved hem and secure zipper
Pockets you can guarantee that this is
the perfect jacket for your outdoor
adventur Reas not to get it so don't
waste any more time guys get yourself a
pair of vessis today go to v.com traste
or click that link in the description
that's right by going to vy.com
trashtaste you get 15% off your order
15% off a pair of shoes a nice jacket
anything you want v.com traste back to
the episode one thing I've never
understood about concerts is like what
is the point of encour what I guess I
think it was probably a cool thing at
once and now it's just expected so I
think it like it's lost its J as as as
now that it's expected that you put like
your coolest song in The Encore then I'm
like well we all know it's coming we all
know you're going off stage here
although I will say I recently went to a
concert of um this like American
Musician Mike canella who I really
really like and he had his like new band
that he was touring with in Japan and I
got tickets to go see it cuz I [__]
love Mike canella and uh they've only
ever released one album right so it's
like very new band but I'm like cool
I'll go watch them they basically did
all of their you know songs that they've
released up to that point and they
started walking off naturally everyone
was like oncle oncle Mike comes back and
he just goes on the mic and he's like we
don't have any songs left and then he
just leaves I'm just like you know what
I respect that it's like it's like Uno
reverse card on The Encore it's like you
know that's that's refreshing feel like
it's why do people [__] saber a
champagne why do they slap it was just
tradition right people just do it cuz we
just did it have you ever say I I want
to I I saber champagne I want a Sab
champag a champag did you do it right uh
no okay well super what did you use you
can ruin the
whole proper yeah yeah yeah I used like
a proper saber that was like this big I
did it with Chad when I was in Melbourne
of course it was withad okay now now now
that makes sense and and I did it and
but it it was like the I guess not the
correct way to do it cuz like theod no
no no it was it was the proper way is
that you know the cork is supposed to
like perfectly fly off and you know no
the the the glass supposed to just
perfectly snap off yeah oh then I did do
it right it was perfectly flat it was
like kind of like at an angle so
likeis clean cut is what we're asking
clean C the risk is that the like glass
shards can go in the champagne as well
as just smashing the entire bottle but
nor you just [__] you just well I
mean it's I mean it's a lot harder than
that but generally yeah yeah I mean yeah
you sabered a champagne bottle I I I
could leave that much of an achievement
that's just such a [__] rare thing to
do really yeah it's like fencing do you
know anyone who fences no yeah right I
don't know a single person who's fenced
but you can say that about like most
Olympic sports okay okay name sport huh
equestrian I don't know if someone who's
equestrian [__] off you do I don't know
anyone who's fenced who do you know
who's an equestrian I mean I lived
around farms and [__] so people did that
[__] what on sheep on on horses just get
on your RAM just fuing drum the vence I
don't know s I'm pretty I'm convinced
fencing is a
lie not met a single person who's fenced
what what what do you mean conspiracy
what it's a conspiracy created by the
Olympic Committee I don't think it
exists right I think they just they they
they just find five dudes who are
willing to do it and they tell us it's a
real thing okay fencing's real let's
keep it exciting I think we should take
the armor off in fencing take the armor
off and just go back to old school just
just let them Slaughter each other what
do what does the need like the little
well the original Greek uh sorry the
original Olympics Way Way Back had fight
to the death so that was should have
that yeah we should bring that back yeah
bring that back do you think Esports
should be in Olympics no no I like we
went from me joking about fencing not
being
real no they did about the real they did
try this and it failed Mis yeah it did
fail I believe so oh yes uh
Olympic sport like last year I remember
it was a whole funny thing what in Japan
yeah no not in Japan in general just in
general oh like the Winter
Olympics wait what well cuz last year
was the Winter Olympics right no no no
like the like I think the previous
Olympics that happened oh like I yeah
there's something something could you
look this up K yeah something happened
last year where they did something and
it was it was a mess they [__] it all
up what were they playing I don't know
this is the problem with gaming right is
that there's only a few games that have
stuck around long enough to really be
like I guess have that Olympic feel to
them of like a a thing we all know I
just can't imagine being like all right
so here's the swimming and here's the
gymnastic and then there's Quake there's
no games that feel Olympic you know what
I mean that's that's that's my Mario
Tennis get the [__] out
Joey they can play it right after the
tennis I mean they did um the only
people who I think of the biggest
example I can think of something similar
was OverWatch did their their Global
OverWatch competition where it was
country based yeah and it was it was you
know it was it was different from the
league it was just purely a like whose
country is the best well no because uh
league is in the Asia games uh which is
kind of like kind of like the Olympic
but just for like the Asian countries
and that's split up by countries as well
well you know Faker doesn't have to
enroll for the military anymore yeah I
saw that yeah yeah it's because he won a
gold medal at the Asia games I love how
I love how BTS couldn't get an exemption
from serving in the military but Faker
could I'm I'm trying I'm not trying to
say that Faker hasn't contributed more
to I'm just saying like BTS couldn't get
it yeah and it's cuz Faker he he won
like they like the Korean team won the
gold medal for the Asia games uh all
they had to do is basically beat China
and they were basically uh Shire to win
uh because of that yeah I can't wait for
League of Legends finals this year I'm
so so stoked so okay going back on topic
though cuz who gives a [__] uh what is
what sport or what game would be the
most suitable for an Olympics situation
Super
Smash cuz like America would just win
this is the problem with a lot of
Esports is that like America just
crushes in so many of them except for
certain games yeah uh like fighting
games is like dominated by mainly
Americans but there are some Europeans
obviously who have like like lean or
whatever or there some Japanese people
who are pretty good them matero in
certain games but a lot of games are
dominated by just America what about Wii
Sports noer no why not it's got [__]
Sports in the name bro Nintendo Nintendo
would ruin stuff somehow it'd be like
we'd be like oh we're doing doing Smash
Bros for to to save dying kids in terms
like we've already put them
down stop stop it shut down we whack
them over our head with a copy of Smash
Bros it's just like Nintendo would find
away cuz someone owns it right why would
we want to play watch Wii Sports in the
Olympics when we have all of the sports
that are in Wii Sports actually
represented you can just say that about
Esports in general then oh I'm sorry
Joey where in name me a real life
equivalent to League of Legends yeah
it's true there shouldn't be one that's
the point that shouldn't exist Counter
Strike other than terrorism which isn't
R we don't have rank we don't want to
talk about Counter
Strike well it's counter two now dead
see us cter two you know okay yeah we
that's that's what we don't want a real
life equivalent of uh but yeah I mean wi
Sports okay here's is is
like should like things like bowling and
darts be part of the Olympics yeah I
think so yeah are they already they're
not right m i don't no no they have
their own like like championships
America will win bowling though and do
no no no no UK or some European country
oh really I have no idea unless they
can't drink while performing in which
case uh the UK just gets nerfed to
nerfed to the ground you cannot take
performance enhancing drugs and the Bri
are like [__] I saw a tweet that was um
it was like let's do like an Olympic
games but where everyone is allowed to
take as many drugs as they want like
let's let's get the the the best
performing human with everything that we
can give them just absolutely max out
all stats are you not curious what how
fast a man could run if he has full
access to
drugs if they're going to do it let's
just let's just make a league for
it what is it like a speedrun strat like
yeah can you imagine how fast Usain Bol
will be when he takes [__] cocaine we
have like glitchless we have glit that's
all the kind of drugs that improve
running I'm pretty sure we have like
glitchless categories in games why don't
we have like drug categories and and
clean
categories that's a great idea what what
would we be promoting here corner what
what would we be promoting that drugs
inan all these vape and smoking
companies would love such to sponsor I'm
sure I I'd argue make more money more
leadership is it legal to take weed
before like professional eaters go into
like an eating
contest that's a fantastic idea um if
they're not doing that they should does
that count as a performance enhancing
drug at that point yeah because you're
on the munchies bro and you're like I
can e 1.5 times the average right now
are so
good yeah they should if they if if
there isn't like an American like if
Matt Stony isn't doing that then I'm
impressed he's called Matt Stony so
maybe there's some
maybe it's in the name yeah it's right
in the name we've figured out your trick
Matt oh how was uh South Africa by the
way oh dude it was sick as [__] like
like cuz I've always just wanted to go
to Africa just because it's like one
it's a continent that you just like
never well I don't know anyone else
around me that has been there before
it's just I don't know it's just like I
always forget how actually massive
Africa is how can you forget that it's
[__] huge because like you know most
like regular world maps that you look at
it Africa is like condensed because of
like you know the perspective actually
because of like the map type you know
Joey but the standard map type that
everyone knows and has seen before like
Africa looks a lot smaller than it
actually is cuz like you know it took us
well for one it took us 20 hours to get
there by flight which Australia BR yeah
exactly yeah but um no it was really
really cool um this convention in
Johannesburg easily the best convention
I've ever been to wow the organization
was absolutely like topnotch like every
single guest got their own security not
just within the convention but even
outside the convention because
Johannesburg is the crime capital of
South Africa um yeah so it's pretty
dangerous so they were like we give you
security for like 24/7 so that like that
was sick as [__] and like just like it
it was massive as well 80,000
people yeah like I thought like oh it's
not even the capital of South Africa
right it's in the [__] one of the
most dangerous cities in South Africa
and it's a ComiCon so I was just like H
it's not going to be that big and they
were like yeah it's 80,000 people when
you went a lot of the comments were like
please be safe yeah exactly and that was
freaking me and AK out just being like
what what's going to happen but we were
okay and like that convention was just
so so cool like they they had like some
of the stuff they were selling there was
just so weird but they were like
treating it like it was normal like
there was straight up selling weed at
this convention what yeah is it legal
yeah apparently and and there was just
like weed like dispensary companies that
were just like selling weed at this
convention I'm like I like you guys like
okay like this this children walking
around like the hell and it wasn't even
like behind a curtain or anything it was
like in the middle of like the
entertainment area but like yeah that
that uh that convention was easily one
of the the coolest conventions I've ever
been to yeah so well on South Africa you
did good and then the Safari [__] that
we did outside was pretty dope as well
we went on like a should fun yeah like
when you when you think of like a safari
like you think of like kind of the Caged
like trucks and you know you walk
through and it's like or you drive
through and you know you see the Lions
and all that kind of [__] that one was
cool but I think the best way to
experience a safari now that I know is
going on a quad bike oh wow yeah but
like obviously they're not going to let
you into like the lion enclosure on a
quad bike so let's see if Joey survives
it's into lion enclosure Saar speedrun
also emptied his
tank but like it was really cool cuz
like you know you you go into this
enclosure on a qu bike uh you know you
get you can get really [__] close to
like wilderbeast and like we I almost
got kicked in the head by wild dra so
that was pretty
fun wait what what so we were we were on
a quad right and I'm just like you know
just kind of let me let me get a snack
first yeah you know I was just kind of
cruising through you know going at like
a slow speed it's like instant death
isn't it yeah it was pretty scary but
like I was I was just you know I was
driving the thing and AR was on the back
of the quad and I was just kind of going
slowly looking around being like all
right let's let's see where the animals
are all of a sudden Ari was like Joey
turn around right now and I was like
what and I look back and like literally
this distance there's a dra's face right
here and it just came out of no like
these [__] are silent Killers
like they he just came up right behind
me literally this far away right and I
just [__] floored it and uh and the
guy was like yeah that was very close um
from what I could see he was very
agitated and if you had stayed there for
enough time he would have kicked you and
I'm like can that kill you and the
African guy just laughed he was just
like just kep going and I was like all
right say less but uh yeah I would
definitely recommend um we're probably
going to go back next year oh [__] nice
yeah cuz there's another one in Cape
Town which is like the bigger convention
and we've already been invited back
so that's the bigger convention that's
the bigger convention [__] and I'm
pretty excited cuz that's where they
filmed the one piece live action so it's
like real life one piece I get to
experience and that's pretty cool one
piece fan this beer sucks what you
backyard Buzz it's a honey wheat ale and
it doesn't taste good really someone
need to tell them that just cuz you add
honey doesn't mean it tastes
good hey don't blame me I just randomly
picked I used to like I used to like
honey things but now after growing older
I'm just it's just a lot of sugar is it
I mean there the thing with beers right
you try and add all this [__] to it
and it's like bro we had we had like so
minimal ingredients for so long yeah if
you can't make something good after
Generations people have made a beer
taste good with barely anything any
added ingredients what are you doing
yeah yeah um so don't add galaxies or
[__] to your beer it doesn't taste good
um this one yeah it's not very good
either it's like we perfected the
formula like centuries ago we added
orange no don't add [__] orange to
yeah just let it [__] cook do you
like fruit based beers no no no a beer
shouldn't have fruit in
it I
agree I was I was trying to think of a
counter argument but I'm like [__] he's
right I I was trying to Pro that like
you shouldn't add beer like fruit to
beer I I I I allow it for ciders listen
like you can add it if you if if there's
a a group of people who don't like to
taste normal beer and they want fruit
that's fine but for me like I I I like
the normal bitter horrible beer taste I
love that flavor um and so when they add
like fruits and [__] to I'm like man I I
don't want to drink this fair enough I
don't know why I went for the honey one
I thought well maybe it might be good
all right what be should I have next let
me see oh this one's so ass there's a
there's a one that starts with a be over
there that
there's the one that starts with the be
right there that you should probably try
out Korean
K
oh what's the be what are you talking
about I've tried buttweiser Joey Joey
it's our favorite beer according to the
trash tase
law let me try a juicy West from
Colorado ooh Christ you don't have to
finish this F yeah I feel like I should
though I don't have many bits I gu we do
no you can try it at some of the other
ones
do you want to try this one see if you
like it let me have a sip of
it uh yeah I can have a sip of it I just
don't think it tastes
good oh the aftertaste is it's just kind
of not good it's a bit water watered
down yeah you want try it I guess this
is going to be episod we're just we're
just trying the beers the
beerus oh that tastes awful it's just
like what is the honey doing in I can't
even taste the honey there's no kick to
it at the end yeah all right well this
one what is this V double mol original
ma
be that's exact amaros
[Music]
nugget what nugget the G's always the
funniest when you read it you can't
understand it could you open this one
for me then let's see the 7% I'll use
I'll use the how you how do you i' got
to learn that I've got to learn that
it's literally physics you just no I
know and I know that every time we you
do this explain it with logic but in
practice I cannot do like every time we
we like watch you on camera get like
Amazed by it all the Germans like oh
every German can do this by the age of
four what are you doing we go to
preschool and open our own
[Laughter]
beers well didn't you need someone to
open the bottles on your uh RV trip yeah
well L just like hammered it against
anything you could find I like what are
you doing I had carry a bottle opener on
these times of purose oh man so this is
from um uh Japan no is it no it's not
you have to say it otherwise the title
is clickbait
yeah we tried every beer from Japan yeah
I bought it from CDI oh it's we bought
it in Japan doesn't say where it's from
does it on the
back Spain [__] never had a good beer
from Spain actually Estella is okay
that's what it's called right that's a
that's Spanish I think that's Spain
Spanish what do you guys think of
cider cider yeah cider I'm not a big fan
I like cider I I I thought I used to be
a fan and as I've grown older I'm like I
think I'm I think I'm good actually it's
hard for me to drink cuz like you know
when I'm when I'm drinking beer the
intention is that like okay maybe I'll
have one but like if I'm like a long
night yeah I'll be drinking like four
beers right that's a lot of sweet drink
to consume for me well that's why I can
only drink dry Siders now like the dry
because like the sweet cuz the sweetest
ciders like it it might be nice to like
maybe start off but like I can't have a
whole night with sweet ciders also like
if you really have like the traditional
cider so like I remember when I was in
when I was in Bristol uni we'd have like
some specialist cider places and you
know I was like cool let's try some
traditional cider uh traditional cider
like that that is made like the
traditional way uh some of them just
smell like feet like isn't like I I
don't know I don't know what the
traditional way to make cider is but I'm
pretty sure they just left some apples
in a [__] barrel for months and just
let them it down with like foot that's
probably why it smells like feet yeah
just bare feet just crushing these app
that wasn't even the worst part some
some of them were just like lukewarm you
know some of them you know in the UK I
think you'd often get served pretty warm
beers and ciders yeah it's generally a
bit warm don't understand warm beers
well not war okay not warm sorry but
like it's not I wouldn't Des that is not
a hot take joke I just not a hot I just
don't get it I've had it before and I'm
just like do you to I think the I'm Paul
M's going to fact check this I'm pretty
sure the idea is is that warm beer is
much easier to drink more of than a
colder beer hold on I'm just going to
look at the window real quick just to
make
sure maybe I'm just if I was a bar owner
I would want people to drink more beer I
just I don't think people need
convincing in the UK to drink
true sure sure the flavor flavor okay
just for of flavor I'm pretty sure
though like if the alcohol is warmer
doesn't it go to your head quicker like
it it gets you're just making [__] up
now I swear to
F no no no I no I'm pretty sure if the
beer or alcohol is is warmer or room
temp it it gets in your bloodstream
quicker than it would does if it's cold
so what you're saying is like
hot wine will get around your body
quicker than like a cold glass white
wine yeah of course anecdotally complete
[__] try no Google it
me
anecdotally but when you open when you
put the window just say
no an like anecdotally like I you know
they say that you get more drunk when
you drink on a plane because of the high
altitude and stuff I think that's true
I'll test it tonight I'll I'll let you
know I'll let you actually one time I
cuz I normally if I have I'm going on
the plane right after this so I guess
I'll well I'll probably just have a beer
before I fall asleep to help because
it's the worst feeling is drinking a
bunch of beer and then you don't go to
bed for like 4 hours and then you go to
bed you're
like oh
God cuz your body's like trying to
digest all of it I was on this flight
one time uh and I don't know why one of
the I I asked for an alcohol free beer
uh cuz I had a meal and I was like yeah
I want I want the taste of beer without
alcohol but that's not the taste beer
it's it no no I I I've been trying to
swap out beer for non-alcoholic lately
yeah um and I know it's yeah well listen
I'm sure calories it's mainly calories
don't drink beer well no sometimes
you're in the the mood where you people
everyone's having a beer and you want to
join in but you don't want to have the
alcohol so I'll just get the
non-alcoholic version it scratches the
same like beer taste that's Carion bro
no genuinely genuinely it's it's it
doesn't taste the same in my op in my op
doesn't taste it doesn't taste the same
but it it it's close enough where like I
feel like if I'm around everyone and
everyone's Beering I'm like all right
well I feel like I'm part of it no just
and zero cops and zero calories no I
think it tastes
metallic just drink a Seltzer at that
point man I just don't want the
calories yeah that's that's why I said
yeah drink a Sala you still have 100
calories I want zero I want zero I don't
I don't want the alcohol as well just
don't want the alcohol mainly as well
cuz I'm like man I got to do [__]
tomorrow for to preface this is not us
giving [__] to our mate for not wanting
to drink alcohol really right now speak
for
yourself I'm definitely shaming this not
what this is not what is happening but
I'm trying to make you the argument
listen I I we booze and smooze a lot you
know uh we have beers occasionally and I
just kind of figured out I was like man
if I'm going to drink uh which ends up
happening like once a week at least in
Japan like if I can just change one of
those days to being no alcohol I'm like
okay well maybe my body will thank me a
little bit more for it oh no I I
completely agree totally and it's like I
said like it's not the exact same taste
but it's close enough for me where I'm
like okay it just about gets that itch
of beer although man does it give me
like the grossest smelling mouth and and
burps for some reason non-alcoholic beer
at least the Japanese ones smell
horrific yeah they smell like coins it's
awful I don't know what metallic I burp
and I like nearly vomit yeah it's gross
but it's only 100 calories no it's
zero zero calories and zero cobs wait
nonalcoholic beer in Japan the the uh
the the Sor olree and the green label
Asahi no green label is alcoholic the
the non-alcoholic Asahi and santor zero
Co well I think two grams of Cobbs yeah
uh or one I don't know what else and
zero calories and zero alcohol and zero
sugars I me so it's like a it's like a
Coke Zero for
alcoholics just [__] drink uh water
at the end of the day
well yeah I mean I'm like I've heard of
that before no no no no but like it's
like again like you want to you want to
be a part of it and sometimes you know
it's it feels kind of lame to order a a
a [__] water when everyone else's got
beer but like at least ordering water oh
okay all right pantic I don't know man I
don't [__] judge if someone's like
that at a hangout it's like all right
you know what like a good I don't judge
I'm like I don't I'm not judging your
stance or not want to drink alcohol
judging the [__] Taste of
non-alcoholic beer which I I've had
enough times at like the when I've tried
to make the same decisions and I don't
know it's it's kind of like being cucked
by beer cuz like you're you're having
you you you think you're having beer but
like it's it's just not the same
fullness of taste I'm drinking beer but
it's notal controversal I've been
drinking I think non-alcoholic aahi
tastes better than aahi do you just not
like beer what the [__] you do do you
not like love beer okay how dare you g
how dare how dare you say I don't like
beer it's the one thing in life I love G
dude you just I don't know cuz for me I
either want a good tasting whatever like
a good tasting beer or I don't want it
at all like I remember like Connor every
time we'd H hang out uh early on you
would drink the green labels which is
like low calorie beer awful beer right
and it tastes awful it tastes [__]
that was mainly cuz I wanted to get at
the time it's like a trying to get the
the drunk Vibe yeah and I wanted to do
it without murdering my body but it
would come at the cost of just having
the worst tasting beer it's actually
legally not recognized as beer in Japan
because of the way it's made it can't be
called beer really yeah and and it's
it's so [__] it's called h hopu a Hu
it's not like it can't I don't think
it's it can legally be called and
referred to as beer No it's h which what
what does that mean in Hau just means
like uh bubbly alcohol yeah right like
it's it's I guess it's kind of like it's
the closest you'll get to like the
calories of nonalc non-alcoholic beer
but keeps the alcohol it's like Hasbro
is my first beer but I actually think
that the alcohol in that because the
beer tastes so bad the alcohol makes it
taste worse but at least because the
nonalcoholic isn't alcoholic it's just
like it's okay yeah I I don't know like
for for me how can I say this does beer
taste good I love the taste of beer I
don't know okay I do not know okay
genuinely
I do not know if I like the taste of
beer CU it tastes good or because I've
like beer peed myself into thinking it
tastes good you know cuz Okay okay every
kid remembers their first sip of beer
right and you remember that first sip of
beer and you're like yeah but as a kid
you don't eat [__] chicken nuggets if
I gave them to you K do you remember the
exact point can beer uh I do remember
there was a turning point uh around like
the age of like 20 where I started to
think huh this is pretty refreshing for
me it wasn't until I moved to Japan and
I had Japanese beer that I realized wow
Australian beers taste like dirt I was
like wow this is actually good beer also
loves like logas and psers like very and
they also like I mean aahi and is like
it's it's like water yeah but cuz like
my first like reaction or I guess like
my f my initial reaction to beer or what
I thought was like this is what all beer
tastes like is [__] VB which is like
the
worst you have to start with the worst
so you can appreciate yeah yeah you know
you have to have some but in my brain I
was like oh if this is what all beer
tastes like then I don't think I ever
want to drink beer ever again and then
when I you know came to Japan and I
started drinking all the Japanese brands
I was just like oh this is actually like
kind of nice I think I remember telling
my parents like I'm never going to drink
alcohol it tastes so bad and then they
laughed at me and then years later they
keep bringing it up yeah my dad laughed
at me and he was just like you're
Australian son you're going to
drink it's like if you are my son you
are going to drink um go I mean yeah I
just love the taste of beer I wish that
there was more non-alcoholic beers that
tasted good so I wouldn't feel bad about
drinking them cuz sometimes I'm like man
I wish I could I could have a beer in
this occasion but I'm like man I just
don't want to have alcohol it's like
[__] but I love the taste of beer itself
uh but only really beer I never get like
I never really like want to drink I
never ever want to [__] drink Spirits
they're [__] disgusting I don't think
I like beer in enough to the point where
I just want the taste of beer but I want
the taste of beer but I don't want
alcohol I I don't love beer as much [__]
I love I love the bitterness I love the
the carbonation I love the kind of
hoppiness of it it's just a and it goes
well with food so well any food you have
tastes so good with a beer or fried food
fried food but any like anything really
I think anything tastes good beer food I
you you tell me any food I I'll say it
tastes good with beer Sushi I think it
tastes great with beer no no no
no it's too light man it's too
light I think it good oh me I got
something to I got something hilarious
tell me later oh okay
okay do you want to say do you want to
say did you just forget we're doing a
podcast right now no you know the the
sushi restaurant the one that we all
love and care about deeply Emily said it
was mid and overpriced oh my God she did
not she did not wait who said that Emily
and da said that it was a mid and they
thought they got scammed cuz it was so
expensive oh my God that's okay that's
fine that is not okay
me I don't know a single you're never
going to watch this episode but I don't
think they can tell the difference I
don't think they can tell differ I that
that was the moment that I I genuinely
lost all hope in their food T you know D
like thought Gregs was mid I just I just
I've never been so disappointed
before yeah but he was also on a steady
diet of [__] microwavable food in the
US as well so like I don't trust them
they have the weirdest food taste it's
like impossible to give them something
[__] made for each other but what the
[__] but not made but not made for
everybody else can't believe thought
that Sushi was made that's that's going
to keep me up at night godamn can't
that's like my favorite sushi place I
have a I have a friend who's visiting
right now who's like like the who's like
born in Texas and he just can't have
seafood and he was asking me for like
restaurant recommendations and I'm like
[__] if you can't have seafood what can
you recommend in Japan that doesn't
include Seafood as well [__] this is a
lot harder than I thought it was to be
was like in when I out with um uh you
think that's hard uh Mudan when Mudan
came his group some of his friends came
over and one of them had uh CDX disas
couldn't have gluten I learned that day
that when I was trying to find a
restaurant [__] everything in Japan
has gluten everything everything soy
sauce gluten miso gluten often is gluten
intolerant like is there even a full
Japanese person that has gluten iny like
is that a thing I think I think they it
got like they were killed I think I
think they they they survival of the
fittest well no I think if you had celex
disease in like [__] I don't know I I
don't know the history of it but I
imagine it's like a thing where well he
died Skil it's it's called Uh Evolution
right bro Daran knew it now figure it
out there the reason why uh I'm I'm not
like toast intolerant and uh one of you
guys specially probably are lactose to
in to I'm slightly lactose in to do do
you think that if we were born in like
the caveman era that You'd Survive or
would you would you be one that died off
thanks to survival of the fittest why
are you saying this God everyone loves
to think that they could survive but whe
oh no I'm saying I'm [__] because I
can't see [__] okay I think i' I'd be
the first to go I think I'd be okay I
know them their music uh we we get along
I like I like smashing things I mean
like even if the thing is like even if
you were like know the music music took
me a while to process
smash some rocks together hang I think
I'd be okay as a caveman I think I'd be
all right I think the problem is that
even if you had the perfect genes as a
caveman that could be compatible with
that time period the average [__]
life expectancy was like 27 so like
that's my life expectancy right
now last trash by the
way oh my God uh the answer is no I
would not I think it be okay you think
you'd be okay I think I'd make it work
cuz I wouldn't know bay exist I wouldn't
I wouldn't have anything to like care
about I just I feel like my my
priorities would be way different yeah
bigest animal you think you could take
home then like one V one fight you you
have weapons though you have weapons you
have a weapon what kind of weapons spear
like like like caveman weap you can take
any animal on with with weapons are you
kidding me that's why [__] that's why
we're on top baby a sharp Rock on the
end of a stick Stone Age Stone Age
weapons I a [__] gun yeah okay of
course if you have a gun you could take
on any animal spawning huh where am I
spawning what you mean what country is
my spawn point what country is your
spawn point uh not England okay well
that's fine cuz some a lot ofr if we're
in a volcanic we're in a volcanic
country there's obsidian very very sharp
by Nature I'll pick some pieces up I
throw it at the animal we're good that's
all that's all you throw it at the
animal bro are you kidding me that's all
I'll be doing my entire life is throwing
things cuz that is our one trait that
makes us the most OP is that we can
throw [__] we no no other no other
animal can throw [__] like us yeah he's
definitely dying folks what do you mean
that is that is the reason why we were
so op as as humans cuz we can just like
sit back and [__] launch things no we
we were op because we were smart well no
no we wer we weren't smart for a very
long time no I'm kidding we were smart
because we managed to think that guy's
that far away I got a stone here I
wonder if I throw it at him and run away
we we're also very good Runners we're
not fast but we have like like not many
other species can like run as as long as
we can if we we have the stamina yeah
cuz like a deer and [__] can't run that
long they can run a they can run very
faster they can run faster than a tiger
and a lion that's all that's important
right uh yeah sometimes
sometimes listen we we throwing [__] is
so valuable no I I agree throwing [__]
is valuable I asked I asked you what the
biggest what's the biggest what's the
biggest animal you think you take Spears
and I can take down an elephant no [__]
no all right Sabertooth could you take
on a sabertooth
uh I probably wouldn't be able to he'
probably catch me yeah for the moment I
throw one spear I'm gone an elephant
though what the [__] do you think you
could take on an elephant I just feel
like I could probably get enough Spears
down no that the skin is like tough as
[__] on that thing yeah but if you have
a really sharp thing you'll be
[Music]
right listen I've played elen ring right
I can I can dodge and roll around the
elephant his his AOE you don't have you
don't you don't have frames [__] I don't
have eye frames I think I think maybe
with the enough Spears if I was really
really dude imagine imagine how happy
The Village would be there if I brought
back an elephant I'm like guys I'm going
to need everyone to come out for this
one we got a we got a whole as like why
why what yeah I mean I'm sure but like I
don't think like throwing a couple of
Spears is going to take it down I think
have a good good crack at
it it's like the new season of T like so
how did Corner die so just he just
decides not Chuck the spear at the
[__] Elephant D you could dig a
really big hole and like lead the
elephant into the hole
well like like Pitfall like a Loney
tun like wild coyot kind of deep are we
talking right now like if I dug a 6ft
hole that is like just wide enough for
two legs of the elephant to fall into
yeah it'd be stuck right in no way it'
get out what you mean what no wait wait
are are you talking about [__]
implanting the elephants with four
different holes for each leg no no no
like one giant elep sized hole that
could theoretically fit two elephant
legs right like a bit of it it's
buttocks and if it went in over the the
thing right I put leaves like a Lune
skit and it walked over I let it maybe I
stabbed it and ran over it you look it
would fall into it it would didn't know
it's a
hole I think it would fall in and if it
fall in it wouldn't be able to get out
cuz there's no how's the elephant going
to climb out oh you talking about if it
like Falls in and lands on its back no
no just like even if its legs went in
cuz I don't no cuz then it could just
back up and just be
like or it would or it would continue to
walk forward and just [__] walk out
what if it I no I think it's too top I
think it's too heavy I don't think the
only way that that would work is if the
hole is the length of the elephant and
it just like Falls no I think I think a
Looney Tunes comically half hole the
elephant would work have you not seen an
elephant stand on two legs yeah it could
get out that
way okay okay now okay okay we're
doubling the size of the you reck it
would fall in there it's not like it's
not like link like old school link where
it can't jump like it can it can it can
jump that just I'm just imagining
caveman C of being like boys perfect
plan we have a hole it start it starts
like getting up on his hind legs this
[__] can't jump think I think we
get enough if there was four of us we
get enough stabs in to to to take the
elephant down it take a lot of stabs
that's the reason they had war elephants
back in the day man yeah well they
actually weren't that
effective were they not I don't think
they were that effective well like the
the Persian Empire and stuff like that I
don't think they were that effective
yeah I think it's pretty easy to take it
down man watched one one film of like
300 I got
I just throw speed
hard right there there there's 30 of the
boys together in their Spears and
shields right the Elephant Rocks up I
think we're all collectively are like
we're going for the elephant we're going
for the elephant everyone throws their
spear you land enough Spears in the
thing like you won't walk anymore no no
no no because like if you have a group
that's different because you would like
you someone would have to like take
aggro while like everyone else is like
throwing spear juggle the aggo bro no
literally you would have to like juggle
the aggro that's what you would have to
do bro like all right switch up load up
reload next wave yeah yeah
yeah do you think kman at that level of
[__] life obviously they they like
took Downy mammoths and yeah but they
they probably took it down in great
numbers like it wasn't they weren't like
Min maxing that [__] oh no no they
definitely were Joey if your life was on
the L you came a dumb you you yes they
are no they weren't dumb all they did
was that's why we evolved to now where
we're talking about
maybe we are the dumb ones Joey that's
why I'm saying I would not survive no
the only that made the the only time we
stopped carrying is when we figured out
like farming yeah they were like well
guys I guess uh hunting's kind of
pointless now yeah all we got to do is
just shoe flies away and stuff like you
you do you think like caveman cavemen
use any brain capacity to figure out
[__] the economics of like their
country or [__] or like how black holes
work no that all they were focusing on
was how to take down his fuing yeah was
how to take down this [__] animal and
survive listen I reckon even two of us
could take down an elephant I think all
right that's bit that's that's a bit
that's bit much I I was thinking like 51
minimum I think with 10 of you it'd be
easy yeah that's what I'm saying that's
probably what they
did they saw they saw the size of this
giant [__] creature and they were
like well uh you know Steve isn't going
to take it on by himself we should get
everyone in on this [__] I just think
fishing just sounds a lot easier
yeah what if you're in land yeah true
true hope you got a pond or something
yeah yeah just hope you spawn in the
right place right yeah well most places
did most places most places were
water water most of people did tend to
go near the water yeah even they didn't
spawn there they were just see that's
why the Japanese figured out farming
immediately and they were like oh wow
this is so much easier they figured it
out yeah they like oh rice it can it can
feed everyone and we don't have to
[__] hunt for this [__] I suppose so
yeah figure it out if you were actually
like if you were actually stuck in a
battle royale which character archetype
do you think you would be like honestly
honestly what do you mean by character
archetype you know you've seen [__]
Battle Royale You' seen Game you've seen
Battle Royale literally there are
character archetypes there okay Jo I
wouldn't be the i' be the sniper I would
be the
Archer yeah but I think I'd be a bit if
I was if I really was in it I think I'd
be a bit indifferent towards the killing
after a while I'd be like well you know
it's either me or them I guess so yeah
but I mean okay here's here's here's the
thing right because you you know we like
to think that we'd be X character y
character but you get one shot you know
you get you get one you you don't get a
million [__] Dark Souls tries you
don't get to figure out if I frames
exist you don't get to figure out you
know the boss attack patterns and all
that [__] you get one chance you know so
like I'm you know I'm thinking most
people would just probably Camp it out
yeah I would be like the the like wussy
hoarder
I just like gather everything and just
monopolize all the supp I dig a seven
foot
hole I leave people into the 7even
foot like CU in in every like Battle
Royale [__] show like it's like the
you know the [__] Chads that like you
know go out and kill people that always
come out come out on top but to me I'm
just like surely they're easy targets
right surely they're like no those those
types of guys are the ones who in a real
life situation they're going to die
first I mean a real you just make a team
you just try and make a team that's your
best bet right just get a part of a
where are we dropping
boys you just pray the first people you
meet it kind of chill and they it works
out that's uh I think I'd stake my bet
on that I'd be like well my life is on
this 50/50 I don't know man I've watched
squid game it didn't work
out one of going to betray you if you
incentivize killing each other then yeah
I guess though but if you don't then you
know I gu you're talking like like an
apocalyptic like survival situation
right yeah yeah yeah obviously yeah fine
yeah I guess okay that's different cuz
like zombie apocalypse is different from
like a battle royale kind of like
situation you might need to kill someone
to get their
food uh you mean in zombie apocalypse or
just any apocalypse someone's not going
to give their food but you're about to
you know you Des need food or water you
know is that what you were like during
Co I was I was going to kill goddamn
food my bathtub is not feeling gone
sorry sorry
G if a zombie apocalypse happen you be
that [__] in like episode 4 or
whatever in Last of Us yeah he's like
all right guys I'm going to go and then
immediately die just like holding up and
being like this is my place right now
you cannot come in I have a working b
day right here and is not for sharing
actually I mean theoretically there'd be
enough oil if you could get a hold of it
and generate it you could probably like
live if you got super lucky you could
live comfortably yeah' be very tough you
could at least get a few good years
that's my biggest problem with Zone 100
they they just have working electricity
I'm like I'm like how how oh we the
running zombies killed everyone but the
uh the workers at the power plant as
long as they never leave yeah it's so
convenient it's like we everyone is a
zombie except the essential
workers cuz we need them they're not
animals they're just zombies
you they're like oh you run the the you
run the plant the YouTu are the first to
die you just love these like
hypotheticals this is just like I don't
know when men have like
when just men have just like is this is
this the most like bro conversation I
think it is you know well I think I
think I I bet they're talking about
girls it's like you would die in
this I I I think I've had this
conversation a few Fair few times with
other fellow men I think I yearn to just
be in a survival situation where I'm
forced to just learn the basics yeah
just learn how to just do everything
myself okay as a guy okay okay shopping
right okay do you go do you when you go
shopping do you know exactly what you
need and go straight for it or do you
ever go shopping and you're like I don't
know I just want to go shopping I don't
leave the house unless I have a written
list of [__] I need to
buy know I
mean I'm pretty sure that's a dude thing
right like it's like it's like I don't
understand like Ary who's just like yeah
I'm just going to go out shopping do you
want to come and I'm like yeah yeah sure
what are you buying and she's like I
don't know and I'm like what do you mean
you don't know yeah I mean I don't like
to buy things unless I need it but I do
understand that sometimes you're like
man I just want an excuse to go outside
and sometimes just checking stores is
nice and sometimes you see something
you're like man I didn't know I wanted
that but I no but I find that kind of
stuff as I am as I'm going through the
list of things that I need like I would
happen to find something where I'm like
oh that's actually kind of cool and I
would buy that sometimes like like go to
a store this is mentality where I have
no goddamn clothes though cuz I don't
[__] go out to [__] clothes I'm
like I have perfectly good clothes right
now that is true true and that's
probably why I need to update my drawr
as well and Joey Joey instead of just
going shopping just made his own [__]
clothing companies instead of just say
like I was so sick and tired of every
time I would go out shopping there would
be a list of [__] that I needed and then
just right next to the supermarket there
would just be kind of like a cool
clothing store and I'm like I'll go
check it out cuz I've got some time and
I was just like damn I'm wasting like so
much time and money on this [__] I'm
going just do it myself men be like I'd
rather just make an entire [__] brand
and clothing company to just go out
shopping for myself I just realized how
dumb I am I read this [__] Spanish
beer out a German accent
before it's actually not bad as well
it's not bad nice Spain this is much
better than the other [__] very good we
had this moment with uh daus uh when
when he was in England where I was just
showing them around I was it was like me
uh daus uh Sydney and Emily and I we
were just going to like show them around
Brighton and just have like a nice time
and I remember um they just wanted like
I think uh Sydney wanted to pick up
something in like the mall uh so we went
to the mall and as soon as we go in the
mall like Sydney goes into like the
clothing shop that she needs to go to to
pick up something and then Emily sees
like a clothing shop that she wants to
go to and uh she spends like a lot of
time going through like different
clothes and everything like that and
then we had a moment where Emily gets
some clothes that she just happened to
see when we were just out and about
right right and the girls are like oh do
you want to continue like looking at
stores and we were like if we're going
shopping as as like the partner I need
to like mentally prepare myself to go to
like have like the shopping day you know
you know what I mean I don't know if
this is a me thing I totally get what
you mean yeah like like I I thought we
were just going to go out and explore if
we're doing a shopping day like as a guy
I need to mentally prepare yeah I don't
really want to go shopping unless I'm on
the mood yeah yeah it's like oh I'm
about to be the luggage
carrier God damn and then like daus had
the exact same reaction to me and I'm
like is this a guy thing where toally if
we go shopping we we like okay here's
the thing we're fine having a shopping
day we just need some time to like
mentally prepare to have a shopping day
we you can't just like spring it on us
we can't just go out and sudden we're
goinging we need to like go out to be
like okay it's not as spontaneous as it
is for girls right yeah yeah with girls
it's like you don't even have to second
guess it it's like you know what I got
some time uh you know my girlfriend is
here with me let's just [__] go
shopping whatever check out some but for
the guys it's like all right let me
think in the recesses of my brain what
am I missing in my life that I need
right
now let's go and if I'm and then the
moment you buy that thing you're like
going
home you know what I mean like yeah yeah
I got everything I wanted that's I don't
have to look at anything else I thought
for me I was mentally scared because as
a kid my mom would always take me to
like the car boot sales basically garage
sales but like English version sure and
I would go to like the one table that I
always knew was there that had like kind
of like games and some DVDs I I go to
that one table and I'm like Mom I'm done
and my mom would spend like 3 hours was
there looking for antique stuff and I'm
like I'm I'm I'm ready to go home now
Mom I'm ready to go home and I never
understood my dad until I got older who
we he take her to the car boot sell and
he just stay in the car the entire time
the the the correct thing would have
been to leave and just come back later
yeah like just tell me roughly when
you're done and I'll I'll come and pick
you up I'm going to go home and sit on
the couch be comfortable yeah and I
never understood that Dad energy until I
realized now that I'm old and I'm like
oh I would have done the same thing yeah
totally I I had a cold sweat the other
day thinking about a decision I made
when I was younger and I wish I could go
back and slap myself
what I really wanted uh to get Twilight
Phantom princess on the Wii and I
remember I I gave I I traded in like 30
[__] did you call it Twilight Phantom
princess do you mean Twilight
Princess you made I was like is there a
Twilight game called Phantom princess
princess [__] what the [__] Twilight
phant Princess bro the be be this is 7%
be be hitting
me uh Twilight Princess I was like damn
they made a Twilight game on the Wii
it's twilight princess right it's
twilight princess Legends of Twilight
Princess where the I think Phantom
Hourglass and Twilight Princess yeah
[__] okay yeah uh Twilight Princess on
the Wii and uh I traded in like [__]
20 GameCube games and a bunch of like Mr
Game and Watch Game Boy games oh my God
and I think it was like now if you
bought them I think it be worth like 400
bucks oh easily especially the GameCube
games I gave in I'm like [__] I think I
traded in like Super Mario Sunshine
Smash Brothers all the sh just for one
damn game dude Super Mario Brothers and
Smash Bros by itself would like rack you
at least 100 bucks just with those two
games in Japan right now I had Luigi's
Mansion too I think that's worth like
that was even worth more oh yeah cuz no
one [__] bought that game in Europe I
did yeah I know it's rare though it's
actually it's worth a lot well it's
worth more than it was when you bought
it oh [__] I still have mine keep
I just I just wake up like why did you
trade it in just wait a it's crazy to
think that like the value of Nintendo
games just go up but like well that's
what happens when you don't allow people
to buy your games
yeah uh play [__] Rolexes but it's
just like artificial SC scarcity dude
yeah am I an idiot I can't [__] open
this you good man I don't I don't have
any fingernails thank you never do I
know I don't think in the history of our
friendship I've never I've like you
always have trouble open this the one
thing I wish I could get rid of I get my
[__] nails to like goom mask levels
and I'm like I guess I should cut rid of
them [__] scraping my inside my
butthole when I'm wiping myself I mean
so like I should C them that's how you
get hemorrhoids no I I I just like
letting them grow out because I love the
satisfaction of like seeing it like the
difference it's like a before and after
for Like a Pimp My Ride but for my hands
that's like I'm the same but with
toenails that looks nice M like with
with my toenails cuz with with my nails
it's really annoying because you see
them on a daily basis but
toenails you you can't see them but they
get way thicker than like the
fingernails how do you fight the urge to
to clip your toenails the correct like
cuz I you know you're supposed to CL
clip your toenails just straighted be
like flat yeah [__] off no you're not
you didn't know no no apparently that's
what you're supposed to wait you didn't
know this you know this right no I know
this wait wait wait what they're not
supposed to be curved supposed to be
flat supposed be flat [__] off no at
least that's that's how I was is your
first time hearing this yeah this is
genuinely this just this is genuinely
the first time I'm so your fingernails
totally fine to do that but your your
toenail should be cut like at like a
like completely like
straight it's checking right
now all right get those little grippers
out let's see I just cut them like
literally two days ago yeah no you
shouldn't do that that's how you get
ingrown toenail that's how you get
ingrown toenails yeah you know what I've
got ingrown toenails for my entire life
I've I've never had an ingrown toenail
did you got them straight yeah just cut
them straight but I I always have that
urge to like I want to clip off the
edges yeah I've done that as a kid and
it was uh didn't go well so the because
the way that it grows for some reason on
your feet it'll it if it's straight
it'll grow outwards like that but if you
already have it like that it will grow
like you know if you think about the
shape the way it grows yeah cuz it
naturally is going to curve outward well
I don't cut it like too deep which is
pretty [__] deep there's no there's
no nail there no nail left I've gone
pretty [__] deep on it kind of how
mine toenails look as well what how yeah
cuz I I like I don't know okay okay when
you say straight I just follow the
straight yeah yours is like dead
straight see that's that's straight
right there I think you just have
straight toes no
no I think you just have straight toes
my to straight no gone I just cut them
straight what okay okay it looks weird
it looks weird when you cut it but I
swear Follow The Line I follow the line
no you're not supposed to you're not
supposed to no not on your toenails did
you not know this no stop doing
it you don't want an ingr and toenail
that shit's hurts I know it's heard it
before yeah well I thought everyone knew
this oh Na's checking now too everyone
in the office is checking their toes
right now you know this I thought this
common knowledge I mean I knew about
it where where did you hear this from I
just heard it a bunch not supposed to
not supposed to cut your turnils that
way you [__] your turnils too oh God
yeah cuz Southeast Asian thing Kai do
you know about this no okay okay thank
me did you know about this no but I know
like the poor people rich people what
what oh wait what did she say she said
she knows the poor people rich people
feet thing what you about your feet oh
yeah
wa hold on hold on are you saying that
if you just look at wa you never
explained to me okay let me show you
what me sent me like I'm just chilling
one day is it is it the is it the palm
reading is at the
same I'm I'm just chilling I'm I'm just
chilling one day right and then me sends
me me sends me this image and says and
asks me what what feet do you have a
Roman foot a square foot a Greek foot or
an Egyptian foot I have who the [__] is
a square foot I have I have a Greek foot
I have a you have I have the Roman foot
you have a Roman foot no no no cuz it's
like curved no yours is like it's
straight and yours is kind of like that
so yours is kind of like in between a
Roman and a Greek foot I'll take it
mine's mine's straight up a Greek foot
my my second toe just [__] jots out I
have like between between a so what's
the point of
this so wait wait so what does you never
told me what what what mine means so is
it your middle toe is long no my second
toe is really long so I have a I have a
Greek foot you have a joyous life okay
this is I have a joyous life what the
[__] you might as well stop reading my
[__] Palms at that point like it's
the same thing what about your feet
Conor uh his is like in between a Greek
and my second my next one to the the
Roman one is more close yeah he's like
Roman as well so it's like three the big
one and the second one and the third one
are the same no no it's it's slightly a
triangle but not by a lot slightly a
triangle oh you have a romantic life you
have a romantic life apparently
she this is copium of the high is this
what people do when they're bored yeah
this looks no I think this is you being
bored oh wait I'm going to send you guys
a test and and we're going to so there's
a new personality test that mein sent me
oh my God all right let's do it but it's
actually pretty fun right cuz it's like
we we'll take a break cuz I do I do need
to go to the toilet um but the way they
do it it's kind of like Pokemon
types so so I love those unhinged like
which Pokemon would you [__] so I I did
my test and for like a lot of it
obviously it's like a call reading was
pretty inaccurate but for like the types
that it told me that I would like get
along well with mine's in mine's in
Chinese you can you can switch Yeah I
didn't see that part all right let's see
I should do it my you are now oh my God
this is already so pretentious you are
now embarking on a journey to explore
your innate personality relax and take
why does love these I don't it help you
understand people no I don't think it do
all right let me all right let's let's
do this uh test people are so unreliable
cuz I've met people I'm going to say who
who tell me their personality type and
I'm like that's what you think you are
that's not what you are you're very
different to your image of yourself we
all are cuz we all view ourselves very
differently to how we actually are and
we're terrible at being honest with
ourselves I think it's also like
perspective Bas as well absolutely yeah
I think you don't need these quizzes
because you can read people oh okay so
you can't like you need to understand oh
I didn't I didn't understand it from
that perspective I guess that makes more
sense yeah did you see that video about
the the guy he's he's this new YouTube
is kind of like blown up he did this
video about like 10 animals that love to
get
high and I didn't know about this but
apparently Dolphins will like lightly
bite poisonous puffer fish and kick it
around to each other so they can all
have a bite and get high [__] yeah what
are we talking about
dolphins I know me I hang out with
Sydney and you two talk about that [__]
all the time apparently King lemur uh
black lemur sorry they just like find
poisonous like centipedes and just like
lightly chew on them and pass it around
to each other and get [__] stoned I
mean the biggest the biggest is just so
funny the biggest stone is in the animal
kingdom of koalas yeah also apparently
uh birds and bees they just sometimes
they get high on or drunk on like
fermented fruits and stuff as well I go
all right so we just did this
personality test that Meen sent us um
I'm a what what type were you I'm water
type I'm light type I'm a Steel type oh
[__] apparently my least compatible
types are ground and water I feel like
you and I are not
compatible appar apparently I'm most
compatible with light type so but this
is also [__] because my inate my
compatible with me is [__] dude my
inate personality there's like a bunch
of them go big or go home it is what it
is no excuse I'm ready and I'm a 10 out
of 10 that is not me that's not him that
is not me discing you believe in the the
Chinese zodiac symbols for you they they
mean anything to yourself Chinese zodiac
symbols yeah they're like different
zodiac Sy you're the horse that's a
[__] good year what are you
rat hey he won okay he won number one
baby we don't lose say less we win at
any cost I I'm a dog it's a good boy
good boy I'm a good boy well so op
because I have a cousin who's like Year
of the Dragon and I'm like imagine being
Year of the Dragon that's next year
right I think I think it might be next
but like that's just like so
overpowering to every other animal on
like what are you I'm a dragon [__] all
right all right all right the rat won
the race that's all that matters bro
that's all that matters sounds like
copium to me he won he won I don't know
it's the best you won you won the race
and also start of the plague so you got
to have an up and a downside dragons are
extinct what did you get as your inate
personality light yeah oh yeah what what
are the five things that oh it was okay
[__] I closed it but it was like I'm
excited to do it I'm a bit lonely I'm
happy or something I was like this all
doesn't sound like me at
all what does yours say uh my inate
personal this this just makes me sound
like uh this just makes me sound like
botchy basically so uh in a personality
worried no news is good news okay
regrettable he's sles knows me calm down
and it's just like a a water droplet
with like sweat drops that just sounds
like a paranoid
schizophrenic it's like oh God what's
going to
happen oh my goodness yeah so um thanks
Meen uh for giving us a [__]
personality
test but at least I know uh we aren't
compatible Jerry cuz you know that's wow
what a shame we have to we have to stop
talking to each other I think I think we
need to stop trash taste because uh we
water is super
the the glue that holds it all together
someone's got to bring the boys together
the the Nick Fury of trash taste some
call
me you have the same personality type as
Sydney apparently light yeah Sydney got
light as well dude I well half the
questions I didn't even like the answers
to we we'll link it the one that we used
yeah the the moment where the question
was like you encounter a talking bird uh
in the cave that starts like saying all
your option I was just like where was
the kill it option it's like what the
[__] a bird is talking to me kill it I'm
hungry actually I need to eat you know
in in real life you always have the the
attack prompt there but we just never do
it
[Music]
true never it's actually factually never
worth it we always choose to run yeah we
always choose to run or use items or
escap call a friend or so I I was do to
Meen earlier this week cuz Milan's
apparently like starting a farm and some
[__] and she's going to get I saw that
yeah you saw that yeah she's going to
get chickens and stuff wow yeah we're
just casually talking about
you she's going back to a Southeast
Asian route yeah so my big question is
okay you have an animal on your farm
that you know you're going to kill one
day for food yeah do you name it yeah of
course this isn't a hypothetical this
actually happened to me oh this actually
happened to you my grandma owned two
chickens and uh we named them they were
pets and uh when they got too old to l
we killed them and ate them you can you
can love an animal and I think that a
part of the process of life is just you
know ultimately if somebody has lived
its life and you eat it and it gives you
it furthers your life you know and I
think I think that yeah I'm happy to
know that those chickens that like my
grandma and I and like our family car
for is part of me now yeah you know I I
you know I I think that if you're going
to take care of a chicken and show out
love you know and then it gets too old
you may as well eat it you know I get
why Fujimoto ate his gold dude
like
you head of the C it's part of me now
animals eat animals all the time you
know what I mean I we're just a bit more
compassionate and weird about it that's
true ever since we had an abundance of
things you know especially fig a
privilege we figured out like [__]
junk food and I think it all went
downhill and we were like how do we make
everything
[__] well here's the thing okay I don't
know if I've ever like brought this up
on trash tast cuz it feels like a topic
I've already brought up but I don't know
if it's something I've done in private
or not but like okay why is it that all
the food that like taste good are [__]
for your body why why why why why is
beers like [__] for your body it's just
you know God's C why is McDonald's [__]
for your body when it's like the most
processed [__] but it tastes [__]
Godlike I mean cuz we figured out what
the human body identifies as being tasty
generally and it just so happens that if
you put all of those things in one and
prepare it in a certain way it's
generally bad for you like the one thing
that I think people like burgers can be
kind of healthy for you if you cook them
in a certain way and prepare it in a
certain way it's just the way we cook
them and we add all this [__] to make it
bad yeah but why is it the fact that
like all of these like superfoods that
like people say like oh yeah it
increases your life expectancy it
improves everything healthwise most of
them just kind of taste like ass yeah
like like surely surely if like the
human body like if if evolution was a
thing surely would be evolved to make
the good tasting food also like the best
food as possible for our body as well we
like we need fat and other kinds of
things that we commonly now because we
don't need to we don't need fat as much
to survive as we used to yeah but you
needed fat and fat was the thing that
made things taste like great you know
butter you know yeah that kind of stuff
would make things taste amazing so I
think I I don't think it was negative
it's just in the Modern Age It's become
negative cuz we don't I don't need to
stay warm in Winter I can just put a cat
on made of some crazy chemical that
somehow keeps everything in and
everything out like you know we've we
are just living in a time where the age
to that all the rules have changed
drastically in 150 years so now suddenly
it becomes a lot harder and then we
figured out how to process [__] and add
weird chemicals to stuff that are
terrible for us and we used to put
[__] Asbestos and stuff you could
smoke asbestos
cigarettes how many times you going to
bring this I just I just can't believe
that was a thing that we
did Jesus people in like 50 years being
like can you believe we smoke cigarettes
yeah no no I mean people willingly made
that decision to do that yeah it's just
you know I think that people say that
now there's nothing there's nothing like
I think also taste buds are a big factor
some things taste really good for some
people some they don't but generally
like fatty things and stuff coated in
butter or garlic taste yeah but I've
never seen anyone who's like oh yeah my
favorite food of all time is kale I
[__] love kale I've never I've never
met a single person who's like yeah kale
is my alltime favorite like if I my last
meal if I was on death row would be a
bowl of [__] kale you know what
[__] me up what found out that they
like bred brussel sprouts to taste
better in like the P like recently I
believe that like they taste so much
better now like all brussels sprouts I
think in America at least the brussel
sprouts every single time I go to
America right I always order brussels
sprouts it's goed because for some
reason they taste insane in America when
I was growing up they were like the well
you either like them or you don't but
you know we'll see about it and I I
really like them growing up well the the
meme was that kids wouldn't eat the
brussel sprouts [__] love them
growing up they taste so [__] good I
didn't like them growing up I not like I
loved them it's only when I became an
adult where I'm like I can appreciate
the bit of flavor fact trck this by the
way I can appreciate the bit of flavor
of these brussel sprouts now that I have
a wider pallette but when I was a kid I
was just like this [__] nasty as [__]
fge I don't think I should but I think I
could if I have butter available as well
change the game could you be a
vegetarian oh easily yeah really yeah I
think so for how long you say this now I
just love the way you're saying this
like it's such a brave thing like I
could do it I could live on mean my
vegetarians all around the world are
just like this [__] I will I I
will fully admit I could never listen
the two things I care about most beer
and coffee vegan
friendly good to go also I've had vegan
food specifically in like in California
because their vegan game is off the
charts to be fair it's gotten way way
better it is insane I I'm sure it's some
of the foods are terrible for you but
their vegan level is through the roof
they [__] that tastes way better than
anything I could ever get totally
normally just vegan I'm like how are you
doing this what are you putting in this
food the the hard Choice has never been
giving up like okay go going like go
going like a vegetarian life or
something
to me it's always like the biggest
factor out of in terms of a choice is
convenience you know it's it's like
sometimes all right it's sometimes you
just go out for a bender and it's like
1:00 and you're like do I really want to
be thinking about like oh is this am I
eating something vegan or vegetarian
right now or do I just order [__]
macis cuz I'm like [__] Dr I think he
just adapt you pretty I'm going to order
macas after this
recording I'm already I you just get
really used to just thinking about that
kind of stuff and it's just a different
and you just get very I I I speak to
vegetarians and some
vegans I don't like to associate with
them normally but uh when I do associate
with them it's just easy i i i as
especially in like America America it's
very easy in Japan it's obviously a lot
harder it's getting a lot easier though
for sure yeah I mean there's a there's a
vegan chain I think there's one in shuku
and oh dude I mean like you you you you
think like 5 10 years ago in Japan like
the concept of veganism didn't even
exist here this is one place where I
think one of my favorite pastures in
Japan is gluten and vegan and it should
god tier I don't know how they do it
what are they putting in there as in
gluten and gluten free and veg gluten
glutenfree and vegan free past uh and
vegan uh vegan free no vegans
allowed any vegans is like my honestly
like top three pastes for me in Japan
it's so [__] good really yeah and
they do a vegan tiramisu it's God TI
like I don't know how they're doing this
probably a lot of sugar and a lot of fat
but still very good well it it makes you
think how much of the culinary world is
based on like very few things you can
add a lot of things to make stuff tasty
no no no no like we we've like okay
we've gotten so used to like imagine
Western the Western culinary world yeah
if cows didn't
[Music]
exist like we're [__] we're [__]
yeah like cows are literally like Zeus
holding up the wall right now yeah yeah
yeah like what happens if we don't have
cow and [__] wheat we're [__] you
know like like like so much of it is
based on things that few animals can
provide go for it if the impossible
Burgers the no meat Burgers taste as
good as normal beef burgers will you
will you just be like yeah I'm not going
to eat any more beef I don't really care
yeah yeah me neither well actually I cuz
I stopped uh Burger King in Japan had a
plant-based burger and I thought it
tastes way better than their actual
Burgers yeah and they stopped doing it
I'm like
why like like well your first problem is
eating Burger King well sometimes I
wanted like the burger and I didn't want
to get McDonald's and I used to go to
Burger King cuz they had the plant-based
one it was so [__] good [__] rid
of it to me the Big Choice isn't going
like vegan or like meat place plant
paste all this [__] just give me [__]
that tastes good that's that's all I
really care about you know if if it
tastes good I'm not really going to Care
I've had I've had plenty of like vegan
dishes at like restaurants and like
cafes and stuff where I'm like okay yeah
this is really [__] good like it's
absolutely amazing but I've also had
vegan you know dishes in some
restaurants and cafes where I'm like
this is kind of ass not going to lie
it's it's it's a lot of the times cuz
I've had like I remember my first time
trying vegan cheese and it's very
similar to trying non-alcoholic beer
where it's just like you know it's it's
like it looks like cheese yeah I know
this is like if you're vegan right you
can't have cheese right but you have
that cheese itch maybe you know what it
tasted like it's going to scratch that
itch a little bit
mean I guess but like I I think I think
like ultimately having these options is
never a Bad
Thing [__] garbage like the single
slic cheese can barely be considered
cheese but some people like it uh and
they love it on Burgers don't know why
it tastes good I don't know how they
figured it out but it does yeah I mean
like this isn't me trashing like
everyone who makes the choice who wants
to go vegan because there are like
plenty of reasons to want to go vegan I
mean ultimately healthier probably than
me prob
prob at at the end of the day it is it
is your choice if you want to and I'm
totally fine with that Mak youy which is
I think the big reason a lot of people
don't is not because of an environmental
choice or any ethical Choice people like
if it's convenient and if you know it's
not the mentality is now that a lot of
vegan stuff is done as a replacement to
things people already used to as as
opposed to just hey this stuff tastes
good by itself like in in in terms of
like coming into to it with like an open
mind you know and I think I think that's
the biggest image thing that these kinds
of uh different diets have right now
which is to convince people over you
need to convince them to replace what
they have in their diet now and kind of
use a substitute you know uh whereas for
me I would be very happy to be vegan or
vegetarian if I just had really good
tasting food and I just didn't need to
think about if i' if I had enough good
tasting food that wasn't meat based I
wouldn't miss the burgers you know yeah
cuz I I had I I would have enough things
in my diet you know I like fish a lot
though fish is great fish is great you
know we're we're not even remotely close
to getting like fish textures replicated
like B because they've been focusing so
much on meat true I I taste so much to
replicate meat you know yeah but I I
think also it makes sense to try and
replicate like beef specifically cuz how
much water and how much methane cows
release all that [__] so it makes sense
did you see that video of like the the
there was like this vegan Chef that
tried to make like uh like steak but you
like but just frying a watermelon yeah
did yeah this is [__] and she was like
yeah this uh I
tried it doesn't taste like beef dude
some fish when you cook them right
tastes like steaks totally you ever had
swordfish it tastes so good hell yeah
had uh tuna as well some some tuna some
tuna steaks and like you know like
salmon steaks and stuff like that what
do you mean no some tuna steaks can
taste like steak some tuna steaks can
taste like like meat really good steaks
yeah I haven't had it I I
stop no no tuna
it's they taste like they taste a bit
tougher but to say they taste like an
actual beef steak tougher tougher what
the no no no what the as as in like
to as as if like okay as
in as in like you know fish are normally
like very like flaky and like they're
they they're not only very flaky crumbly
okay that was what I was looking for
like tuna does not always have that
consistency I like that I like that but
to say that it tastes like a beef steak
you can cook a tuna it tastes as good as
a steak and like it can have the the
tech the texture and like profile of a
steak you could
I disagree I'll take you to a place it's
it's I know a guy I know a place I know
a guy I got a guy the the one thing the
one thing is that it's never okay one
thing taste aside is just never as chewy
as like a steak that's that's that's one
thing I've never seen like replicated in
the tuna hate that pot the che hate the
chewy pot of steak oh it's [__]
awesome no I want my food to be like a
tire yeah I want to feel like I'm eating
a rubber boot the per the perfect steak
is when you like you you chew into a bit
and then the like moisture just bursts
out you like have you have like the the
juiciness and the are you kidding me
what the [__] that is my least favor
part that's the least favorite part of
this I'm sorry I'm [__] spinning cuz
I'm getting like so you're talking to
someone who said steak is mid all right
like you can't conv me guys the reason
why wagu steak is the most top tier
steak is because of the juiciness and
the fat that comes out of it it isn't
chewy it's not chewy wagu is not chewy
okay Wag the good thing about
the thing that justs wag you apart from
regular steak is the fact that it's not
chewy and it melts melts on your mouth
it's not a good piece of fish no no no
every bite every bite you take you it it
doesn't even feel like a bite because
it's so tender right yeah because it's
so tender that's that's the whole point
of it every where do the che from you're
saying you want chewy I want chewi no
chewiness okay when I say chewiness it
means like with like with a tuna it just
feels like it doesn't have that same
kind of like not toughness but like it's
uh what's what's the literal word I just
use tenderness to it I don't know like
it it it feel it feels like it just
falls apart no I've had some tuna that
is tender as [__] you can have some
really like meaty boys yeah really good
steak like some thick pieces of tuna
likeo you just get a lot of mercury and
also the thing I just talked about which
is that kind of like juiciness and you
get that I'll take a your place no no no
I know okay they did the
thing like cuz like that fatty tuna does
exist uh but no no we're talking like
regular lean tuna okay lean tuna like
that has like a little bit more
toughness to it but it's nowhere near
the consistency of the steak even even
even a very tender steak absolutely no
we're all going we're all going and I'm
take there we're all going to take a
bite of this it's amazing easy it's it
is expensive it's like $40 for this
bloody thing so good no I'm not okay
here's the thing I [__] love tuna
Stakes tuna Stakes are great that's not
what I'm arguing here I'm I am arguing
like that you are saying that you've had
tuna that tastes like steak which is
just which is I have I have I have no
I'm taking I'm I taking you there I'm
shattering your worldview to when I get
back from when I get back from Vegas if
I have any money left we every time I've
had something that's a tuna steak I'm
like this is [__] amazing is it like
is it an actual steak no what if we just
put it in front of you without you
knowing it was tuna oh that this would
be so [__] easy this would be so easy
because the the the draw of the the tuna
steak is that when you bite into it like
the crust is similar of that to a steak
cuz they can cook it that way they get
really crispy when you get on the inside
it's really soft cuz it's tun that's
that's what I'm saying that's what I'm
saying it's really really soft you don't
feel like the muscle fibers or anything
I don't want to feel the muscle FIB what
you get with the
steak Ste that's why I don't like steak
I hate the muscle fibers that is the
worst part of when I when I bite down to
I'm I'm doing like a [__] scammer
force of like and and and I can't
[__] separate this meat I'm like
Christ a I hate that part of a state
literally the worst part of the state
thank you very much no no no that's how
you know that it's a [__] steak okay
I don't I know it's a steak I see it
give me a good steak how' you like your
steak Joey how' you like your steak
medium rare medium rare okay you get
like a small like the best Stakes are is
when that's like a good balance
obviously you're you're you're making it
sound like a steak as [__] Blue Steak
you know where you're just like yes I'm
[__] animal okay no like a good
medium rare St you you get a little bit
of that you get a little bit of like
bounce back with like the chewi and the
fat and everything that comes out and
then it just goes down good chuna steak
is is just way too soft you don't get
that same resistance steak is a steak
that cuts out all the [__] it's
clearly not meat okay that's that's
that's what I'm saying that's what I'm
saying no man you got to take him to
this CH Ste place man you
shut we're about to lose R
here yeah you're wrong [__] sake [__]
sake I need another
beer toilet food probably tasted [__]
back in the day that's real that's
probably why it was fire huh that's
probably why it was so good cuz they
nothing else to compare it to you have
nothing else but you get like some soup
bone broth you're like damn
okay sound like a
Pikmin do you remember growing up uh and
it was like I don't
know I'm not sure about you Joe but
pretty sure about you Conor huh where I
think Sydney had a similar experience
where you just didn't have as much
experience to a lot of of the different
world Cuisines that were just in your
area you just call me white yeah it's
fine call me white God it's fine no no
no but there but there are like plenty
of Cuisines now that I did not have did
not ever have growing up like Kore being
one of them for example I mean for sure
where I'd never had a craving for Korean
food because I never tasted Korean food
but now that I have tasted it and I know
what it tastes like every so often I get
the craving for it that I just did not
have growing up I think I'd be what you
can say that about anything though that
you first experienced and you enjoyed
like you say that about alcohol what I'm
saying is that when we were growing up
and we didn't have this like worldview
of like all the different things that we
tried we were [__] content man I
think I I told the story once on the
podcast I still get cravings for a dish
that is
just unsavable it was just mashed potato
with corned beef and just mashed up I
[__] always want to eat this I mean
that kind of sounds fire actually it's
so good it's so good I've come around to
corn beef recently just because like I
never like my my my parents like never
like cooked with corn beef like we never
had any corn beef it's like the shittest
meat known to man right and it's like
and then when I started hanging out with
AI and I realized oh corn beef is like
the staple Filipino food to have cuz
it's you know it's very yeah that's when
I realized I was like oh it's actually
kind of fire and now every now and then
I get cravings for like corn beef based
like dishes dude try it corn beef orry
or spam which is the uh corned pork I
think uh try that just mash it into a
bunch of mashed potato it's actually so
good and I as a kid I used to just eat
plates of this thing i' would clean it
up so good I want to eat it there was
there was always that one like food item
that I think like every kid I still
think beans on toast is fire beans on
toast is actually so good for me it was
salami that's not
controversial Everyone likes salami like
like the cold cuts from like everyone
loves
salami everyone loves salami my sister
didn't like salami what the [__] she was
a ham girl I think you're going to tell
me something weird like
nod yeah that okay I'll accept that cuz
salami is just generally loved there's a
lot of Japanese people have never had
salami before that's C it's not do you
guys like blue cheese [__] no yeah
[__] love blue cheese [__]
awful [__] awesome it's like gas in
my mouth it's [__] awesome because
like you know you you have this like no
we like imagine your friend farting in
your mouth 24/7
while I just enjoy the fact that a lot
of people are just like ew Nat you let
it ferment in the ground and then you
eat that [__] and it's slimy and then
here I am in the Western World being
like Oh yeah blue cheese exists where we
just made chees and then we just left
out for too long and people were like I
think I think because I grew up with so
much like fermented stuff like like you
know uh takuan which is just fermented
radish or like you know Nat which is
fermented soy beans that like anything
that was fermented I was just like yeah
this is fine this is normal oh God I
just grew up with that kind of diet like
I would wake up in the morning I
remember like when I was at my my
grandparents house I would wake up in
the morning my my grandma would have
like a bowl of rice with
[__] big balll of n my granddad would
make fresh like uh like you know the the
the Blended squid with the Wasabi do
that that was my breakfast like when I
was a kid and you know everybody else
who looks at that would be like what the
[__] that shit's nasty but for me that
was like that [__] is nasty to me for me
that was the staple breakfast and now
like anything that is fermented for me
now I'm like yeah it's it's fine it's
just [__] fermented who cares good
leave in the door yeah it's fine the
longer it's the longer it's there the
better it is honestly if I had to live
off just tea and bread I could do it I
believe it I could just live off tea and
bread that's the most British thing you
ever said genuinely if you just gave me
a loaf of bread every day and some tea I
think I'd be no complaints you pe out of
me I could not do that you you know the
biggest reason why I think the massive
bread thing became a thing for me
because like I acknowledge now bread
tastes great don't D what you're about
to say I think like bread tastes great
but I can't like reprogram that part of
my brain that puts bread in like a
different category as like what you
would eat as like a main course you know
well as in like you can't look at bread
as a main course yeah like bread to me
fits that same mental category as rice
does where I'm like if I if I eat a meal
of rice that's like a really depressing
meal for me I need something to go on
with that rice that's that's the Asian
mindset
bro like it's it's something that is is
paired with something that adds and
enhances the flavor of the rice you know
or of the bread like it's like having
bread in Europe was great but I'm like
this is a great starter for what what's
about to come you know and I agree with
that do you know do you know how I know
anyone who goes like this is the biggest
test right when when someone goes to a
really like high class [__]
restaurant and the only thing they can
talk about is how good the bread was
that's how I know it was an overpriced
meal man that's that's that's like the
literally 90% of the Italian restaurants
would be
in just so so many times I I like I talk
to someone who goes to like a melin star
restaurant and they're like yo it was
the best bread I've had in my life man
and I believe it I believe it but I'm
like okay but like how was the rest of
the meal tell tell me how the rest of
how they click bait you to the
restaurant BR it's like yo this this the
food is like kind of weird experimental
and it's like it's it's pretty splitty
when it comes the opinion but the Bread
Basket they throw at you fire yeah that
was the best bread all time baby put
some balsamic with some like you know
olive oil on that [__] fire I think
bread can be a main if you need it to be
says that's the European in you bro like
I can't I can't do that I think just
sliced bread is pretty fire I mean
sliced bread can be fire but if I have
just sliced bread I'm I'm I'm going to
be like all right where's the meal
that's equivalent to being like you know
that that bowl of rice was kind of Fire
by itself that's fair enough if you feel
that way yeah or like the plain noodles
was kind of fire you know like no one's
doing that like salted noodles that
pretty is lightly salted noodles are fun
no you don't I do I like lightly salted
noodles no you hot sauce are the best
invention we ever made it's like zero
calories you can add it to anything it's
just great hot sauce yeah hot sauce
unless it's the Nando's extra hotu
there's no way it's zero calories like
Tobasco is like zero calories that's not
hot sauce oh my god well you want it to
like burn your [__] make gates of
hell kind of yeah yeah but also it's
probably zero calories cuz you're not
adding you're not you're not emptying
half a bottle of Tobasco onto your meal
no I think it's actually zero calories
the entire thing it's like very low look
at up is Tabasco zero calories it's like
it's like well I I can believe that it's
very low calories cuz I've seen like the
viscosity of that yeah it's water it's
just vinegar with like extra Spice look
at up Kai 12 calories per 100 G that's
so much that's yeah that's you could not
that's basically you could not apply 100
gr of Tobasco Tobasco
you basically just be Downing Tabasco
that point it's great it just adds so
much flavor to a meal I agree and I used
to not like Tabasco it's so weird I
don't like Tasco really I I love it now
it's like can you just like something
come on like just one thing we like we
like it God no no all right no um is
Tabasco a condiment yeah 100% that's why
he doesn't like
it it's it like it like it Tabasco it's
like okay I don't put it on the same
level as ketchup I'm not going to like
really cuz I just genuinely hate the
taste of ketchup uh with Tabasco it's
always with Tabasco it's always filled
in that gap of like what should be a hot
sauce but not really being a hot sauce
that I want a hot sauce hint of a hot
sauce just like like I never want that
give give give me 100% or give me zero
man well sometimes you have a pasta and
it's like I don't want hot sauce added
to this but I just want a a Sprinkle of
flavor added I don't I don't want to
kick in the ass I just want like a flick
on The Shins you know like it's it's
it's not like it's just like a little
bit me as a tie um if I need that I just
put
some they're like oh would you like a
meal they're like yeah and then you hear
them blending 500 Peppers out back and
they're like all right this is the first
round Chuck that in your pad BR once
once you've had fresh peppers like once
you've had like fresh chilies on
something you like Tabasco is just like
[__] bab I haven't reached that level
when it comes to spiciness I'm still
baby steps right now yeah yeah yeah and
I'm just like I don't if like if I want
a kick I need I like I I I do I I am
privileged I need fresh like I need I
need chilies man like Tabasco just
doesn't do it for me um that that is my
that is just my taste palette that's
fair all right hey look at all these
patrons though um that's it yeah no more
spice for you that's it just look at
them they're there uh they support the
show they're go can you tell the
difference between a tuna steak a real
steak please tell me below no we're not
saying you can taste [__] no you're
you're you didn't want to believe in our
arguments leave it to the didn't want to
believe you didn't want to believe hey
if you want to support the show though
and you want to hear some more drunken
rambling that is absolutely nonsensical
then make sure to support us by going
over to patreon patreon.com traste also
follow us on Twitter send us memes on
the subr and if you hate our face listen
to us on Spotify now leave me to my
lotions have you
seen you seen that
video leave me to my lotions to my
lotions and we will see you all next
week
[Music]
bye and leave me to my lotions up the
floor just cracked I believe I might
fall